de vous accueillir aujourd'hui donc
l'Assemblée nationale pour cette
position publique consacrée à la
nouvelle organisation du contrôle et de
la recherche en sûreté nucléaire la
présentation
tous les acteurs de la sûreté nucléaire
qui ont répondu
d'ailleurs par le passé à l'invitation
de notre office
imposé par l'agenda parlementaire comme
vous savez le 3 février dernier le
conseil politique nucléaire a passé en
revue les enjeux les questions éclair
civiles et militaires cinq jours plus
tard économistère de la transition
énergétique a annoncé une réforme très
conséquent pour l'organisation de la
Sûreté Nucléaire elles interviennent ce
sujet qui nous réunit aujourd'hui
pourraient en effet arriver très
prochainement sur la table de travail de
l'Assemblée nationale dans le cadre du
projet de loi de l'accélération du
nucléaire qui débutera en commission
en début mars prochain le 1er mars
prochain
de mémoire
depuis le début des années 90 l'Office a
toujours accordé une attention
particulière aux conditions de contrôle
de sûreté nucléaire dans notre pays une
question à laquelle il a consacré en 30
ans plus d'une vingtaine de rapport
l'Office a ainsi contribué directement
ou indirectement à la longue marche vers
l'indépendance et la transparence du
système de contrôle de la sûreté
nucléaire et de radioprotection c'est
d'ailleurs le titre du rapport que l'un
de mes illustres prédécesseurs à la tête
de l'Office le député Jean-Yves le déo a
remis en 1998 au Premier ministre un
rapport qui préfigurait l'organisation
actuelle du contrôle
je rappelle que cette audition publique
est diffusée en direct sur le site
internet de l'Assemblée nationale et que
la vidéo que la vidéo sera ensuite
disponible à la demande sur les portails
de nos deux chambres le public et la
presse peuvent poser des questions au
travers de la plateforme accessible au
travers du lien fourni sur le site
internet de l'Assemblée nationale et du
Sénat le lien fonctionne très bien
puisque nous avons déjà reçu plus d'une
centaine de questions voilà ce qui ce
qui montre je le sais
l'importance du sujet et et la preuve
aussi de la présence de nombreux
collègues parlementaires ce matin ici à
l'office on est une preuve vivante
bien je sais de la parole au premier
vice-président Gérard Longuet qui
souhaite également introduire nos débats
oui merci monsieur le Président merci
Pierre dont je voulais simplement saluer
avec beaucoup de styles l'ensemble des
interlocuteurs venus pour cette audition
publique de l'office parlementaire sur
un sujet qui est profondément le nôtre
je ne prendrai témoin mon prédécesseur
éminent Claude Biraud pour rappeler que
si le fils existe et bien parce que le
dans les années
83 je crois exactement
le gouvernement a suggéré au Parlement
une projet de loi qui a permis
d'instaurer cette organisme à ses
original puisque c'est avec le sujet du
renseignement la seule commission
permanente qui associe député sénateurs
et ça marche plutôt pas trop mal il est
évident que l'énergie atomique est un
problème
mondial mais il est en l'occurrence pour
nous un problème français que l'autorité
l'indépendant enfin l'autorité
intellectuelle et l'indépendance des
organismes de contrôle de sécurité est
absolument indispensable c'est une
condition du succès du nucléaire c'est
une condition d'ailleurs qui dans notre
pays a été jusqu'à présent plutôt réuni
d'une façon
satisfaisante même si les exigences de
l'opinion les exigences du système
médiatique sont de plus en plus fortes
aujourd'hui mais pour ma part je ne m'en
plaindrai pas car
ayant une confiance un petit peu naïve
dans l'univers scientifique je pense que
il l'a tout à gagner à la transparence
et à l'expression de ces contraintes de
ces difficultés dans un climat où chacun
peut s'informer donc alors le
gouvernement nous propose de enfin
propose au Parlement de réorganiser nous
nous avons le rôle tout simplement
d'éclairer à travers cette audition nos
collègues députés et sénateurs de ce que
pensent les
experts les gens les plus compétents les
plus engagés
de cette
[Musique]
organisation française de l'Autorité de
sûreté et de la recherche en matière de
sécurité donc vous êtes là pour parler
et donc nous sommes là surtout pour vous
écouter et retranscrire le plus
fidèlement possible
vos conclusions nos conclusions faites
et nourris de vos interventions auprès
de nos collègues parlementaires qui
auront si j'ai bien compris en effet
pierre l'occasion assez rapidement de
trancher le débat je ne sais pas mais en
tous les cas de l'ouvrir et de prendre
des positions
selon les procédures qui sont qui font
la joie de la vie parlementaire c'est
d'ailleurs la confrontation
l'explication l'opposition cas échéant
et naturellement la synthèse sur ce
sujet qui est
passionnant
et pour lequel la sûreté est un
préalable absolu
bien merci Gérard je vais maintenant
passer la parole à Bernard de Rosu qu'un
président de l'Autorité de sûreté
nucléaire qui est accompagnée par
Olivier gusta son directeur général afin
d'ouvrir les débats pour une dizaine de
minutes environ
pour qu'on puisse tenir les les délais
l'ensemble des intervenants merci vous
avez parole merci merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président merci mesdames et
Messieurs les parlementaires de nous
accueillir aujourd'hui pour cette ce
sujet tout à fait crucial que vous avez
évoqué j'aurai un propos liminaire
extrêmement court je voudrais
essentiellement
resituer une certaine manière la période
dans laquelle nous sommes dans une
vision un peu historique correspondant à
ce qui s'est passé depuis une
cinquantaine d'années en matière de
renforcement de l'infrastructure
française d'expertise de contrôle et de
recherche liées au nucléaire pourquoi je
le fais parce qu'il y a exactement 50
ans qui a été décidé la création du
premier service de l'État chargé
d'exercer des missions de contrôle du
nucléaire jusqu'à 1973 le contrôle était
intégré à l'intérieur du CEA et c'est à
l'occasion du la
du Premier ministre Messmer de lancer
finalement un nouveau programme un
programme électronucléaire basé sur la
la conception des réacteurs à ou sous
pressions américaines qui a été décidé
de créer un service de l'État ce service
de l'État a été de taille relativement
modeste et il s'appuyait sur une
expertise qui était à l'intérieur du CEA
expertise bien évidemment distincte de
la responsabilité d'exploitants du CE1
donc ça c'est c'est l'acte fondateur il
y a exactement 50 ans et on voit que
l'acte fondateur lié à la création d'une
entité de contrôle et ensuite de son
renforcement a été dans notre histoire
liée à des décisions importantes fortes
en matière de programmes
électronucléaire
au fil
je n'en doute pas au fil du temps cette
voilà je me dis c'est tiens je veux voir
avec une écharpe excusez-moi
au fil du temps bien évidemment les les
équipes à la fois de contrôle
d'expertise se sont renforcés parce que
le programme électronucléaire s'est
développé et il y a eu un certain nombre
d'événements les événements parfois
dramatiques accident de tchernobyl
Fukushima et dans le domaine de la
radioprotection il y a aussi une
événements d'Épinal qui ont conduit à ce
que les équipes à la fois chargées du
contrôle de la sûreté la radioprotection
de l'expertise en matière de sûreté
radioprotection de recherche en matière
de sûreté et de radioprotection ce sont
consolidés pour faire face aux
événements
et puis il y a eu effectivement le
besoin de structuration de cette de cet
ensemble qui s'est affirmé et notamment
au début des années 2000 a été décidé de
créer l'IRSN en sortant en externalisant
d'une certaine manière l'IPSN qui était
à l'intérieur du seva et en le
fusionnant avec l'opéri pour créer l'ISS
et puis donc les ensuite il y a eu un
deuxième un moment très important lié
encore là à une annonce ambitieuse en
matière de développement nucléaire qui
est l'annonce faite par le président
Jacques Chirac à l'occasion de ses vœux
en 2006 où il a annoncé en même temps le
lancement du programme EPR et la
création de l'ASM en tant qu'autorité
administrative indépendante donc on voit
bien là encore à un moment important de
l'histoire où le renforcement du
contrôle et indépendant de la sûreté a
été associée à une décision prise par le
gouvernement et le Parlement de
développement d'un Abraham
électronucléaire
et aujourd'hui d'une certaine manière
nous sommes un peu dans la même
circonstance il y a une impulsion
nouvelle qui est en cours de débat qui
reste encore bien sûr à valider à être
voté par le Parlement suite aux
différentes consultations des bas qui
sont organisés et c'est à ce moment-là
qu'il est aussi souhaité par le
gouvernement annoncé suite au CPN comme
vous la rappelez en introduction
franchir une nouvelle étape et cette
nouvelle étape consiste à consolider
l'ensemble du dispositif à la fois
d'expertise de contrôle et de recherche
dans le cadre d'une ligne directrice qui
a été définie par le CPN et qui nous
provient maintenant de de débattre bien
évidemment dès lors que le Parlement
votera les amendements qui sont
nécessaires pour le réaliser voilà donc
je voulais simplement propos introductif
dire que on est dans une perspective un
peu historique à chaque fois qu'il y a
des grands moments il y a une décision
d'impulsion sur le renforcement du
contrôle de l'expertise de la recherche
et le renforcement de l'indépendance ça
a été fait en 2006 avec la création de
la SN et là c'est un c'est un nouveau
modèle qui pourrait se mettre en place
qui est nouveau pour nous mais qui n'est
pas à nouveau dans le monde du nucléaire
ce qui est proposé existe d'autres
nombreux pays à l'étranger et c'est ce
que nous souhaitons faire en France
très bien merci de toute façon il y aura
certainement beaucoup de questions à la
fois des parlementaires et des auditeurs
donc nous aurons l'occasion de rentrer
dans un certain nombre de détails par la
suite je laisse maintenant la parole à
François-Jacques qui est administrateur
général du Commissariat à l'énergie
atomique et aux énergies alternatives
également pour une dizaine de minutes
environ
[Musique]
à tester mais c'est à nouveau c'est pas
à moi de le dire c'est probablement vous
évaluateurs internationaux qui le font
de le dire donc dans cette logique là
qui est celle d'une évolution souhaitée
par le par le gouvernement comme le
rappelle le président de l'Autorité de
sûreté du contrôle de la sûreté il y a
évidemment l'articulation à avoir entre
la sûreté la recherche la manière dont
la recherche peut contribuer à la sûreté
et ce que je peux dire là-dessus c'est
qu'évidemment nous sommes tout à fait
plus que volontaire c'est à dire que
nous sommes il nous semble absolument
indispensable que la part de la
recherche soit prise là-dedans et le CEA
est tout prêt à y jouer son rôle son
rôle dans ce qui sera considéré par
l'ensemble des parties prenantes et par
l'ensemble des acteurs comme l'intérêt
général et c'est vraiment dans cette
posture là que moi je voudrais me placer
nous sommes un établissement public nous
nous portons cette dimension de
recherche nous portons cette dimension
d'acquisition de connaissances et nous
souhaitons être contributifs à ce que le
système soit organisé de la meilleure
manière possible
ayant dit ça je pense que je m'en
tiendrai là pour se limiter
très bien merci à vous administrateur
général
je vais maintenant laisser la parole à
Jean-Christophe diel qui est directeur
général de l'IRSN et qui est accompagné
également de Catherine nerviews qui est
directrice générale adjoint de chargée
du pôle de sûreté nucléaire vous avez la
parole
monsieur le Président c'est toujours un
honneur d'être auditionné par votre par
votre office alors l'IRSN c'est l'expert
public du risque radiologique et
nucléaire et les 1700 salariés de
l'Institut que je tiens à saluer couvre
une large un large champ de compétence
croisée
compétences que l'IRSN mobilise pour
bien assurer ses missions
ces activités de recherche de
surveillance d'expertise y compris en
situation d'urgence
il y a scène traite de l'ensemble des
usages des rayonnements ionisants des
procédés industriels à leurs
applications médicales jusqu'aux effets
de la radioactivité naturelle dans
l'environnement ou sur la santé
depuis 20 ans
son travail rigoureux complet et intègre
son organisation actuelle permet de
mobiliser les compétences de l'Institut
à tout moment
pour toutes ces missions
il y a SN fait appel aux compétences de
ses experts et de ses chercheurs en
continu
car l'expertise et la recherche sont
imbriqués et portés dans certains
domaines par les mêmes personnes
la force de l'IRSN c'est la
complémentarité de tous les champs
couverts
la qualité de son travail est reconnue
d'ailleurs je comprends que la décision
qui est prise aujourd'hui n'est pas une
critique du travail de l'URSS
l'appuie technique à l'Autorité de
sûreté nucléaire représente aujourd'hui
25% de notre activité
il y a scène mais son expertise au
service de nombreuses autorités
opérateurs Direction générale de la
santé direction générale du travail
ministère d'affaires étrangères
notamment soins avec la guerre en
Ukraine ministère de la transition
énergétique et je pourrais en citer
d'autres aujourd'hui le gouvernement a
décidé de faire évoluer le contrôle de
la Sûreté Nucléaire et mon intervention
s'inscrit complètement dans cette
logique
mon propos s'articule autour de trois
points clés la séparation entre l'expert
et le décideur
l'indispensable combinaison entre
expertise et recherche
les enjeux de maintien des Combes
naissants de compte parlons les enjeux
de maintien des compétences pour
répondre au rendez-vous industriel qui
viennent
je pense utile de rappeler les
fondements de l'organisation actuelle de
la sûreté nucléaire en France
l'accident de Tchernobyl en 1986 a
conduit à des réflexions sur les
facteurs organisationnels les processus
décisionnels
et sur l'importance des arbitrages entre
les préoccupations de sûreté les autres
préoccupations
les réflexions issues des grandes crises
sanitaires politiques médiatiques des
années 90
sans contaminés crise de lavage folle
ont progressivement amené à modifier le
système français de sûreté nucléaire et
de radioprotection ces évolutions ont
abouti à la création de l'IRSN en 2002
et de la SN en 2006
au cours des années cette organisation a
été très légitimement retionnée
plusieurs fois
son efficacité a été confirmée le
principe de séparation des fonctions
d'évaluation et de gestion du risque est
également au cœur du dispositif
sanitaire
ainsi il me paraît incontournable dans
un système à venir dans le nouveau
système à venir de maintenir une
distinction très claire en trixpertise
et décision y compris dans une même
organisation
à l'instar par exemple de ce qui peut se
faire aux États-Unis
la NRC l'autorité de surta américaine a
ainsi des règles très strictes qui
régissent les échanges entre le
personnel chargé des expertises et les
commissaires chargés de la prise de
décision
de même le principe de publication des
avis technique inscrits dans la loi
aujourd'hui support à la décision
devrait également être maintenu pour
assurer la transparence du système pour
la bonne information du public et
infinie pour contribuer à la confiance
dans le système de contrôle
j'en viens à mon deuxième point
l'indispensable combinaison à la
création de l'IRSN il a été fait le
choix de rassembler expertise et
recherche
les compétences techniques de l'URSS
reposent sur d'importants programmes de
recherche avec les industriels français
et les partenaires européens et
internationaux
les recherches expérimentales permettent
de développer des codes de calcul
indispensables à l'expertise tout comme
en situation de crise
dans son rapport provisoire
d'évaluation de l'iracn que je viens de
recevoir le Haut Conseil à l'évaluation
de la recherche et de l'enseignement
supérieur qualifie le modèle expertise
recherche de l'IRSN de je cite
performant et de structurant pour les
grands programmes et réseaux européens
les avis de l'IRSN expriment un état des
connaissances à l'état de l'art
l'engagement de nouveaux programmes de
recherche anticipe des problématiques
nouvelles
la séparation des activités expertise
recherche sera complexe car ces
activités sont parfois exercées par les
mêmes personnes dans un schéma ou
expertise et recherche ne seraient plus
dans une même entité il conviendra de
permettre à la partie chargée de
l'expertise de disposer du budget
affecté à la recherche en sûreté
nucléaire et en radioprojection et de
pouvoir être de pouvoir être ordonnateur
des programmes de recherche
j'en termine monsieur le Président par
exemple de maintien des compétences
je veux y être extrêmement vigilant en
réponse aux enjeux climatiques
énergétiques et de souveraineté la
relance du nucléaire a été engagée de
nombreux dossiers d'expertise sont en
cours à titre d'exemple la prolongation
des réacteurs du parc en exploitation de
40 ans l'examen de la demande
d'autorisation de création du stockage
souterrain Cigéo à venir le dossier
d'autorisation de création de l'EPR 2 si
le programme est effectivement engagé
cela entraîne une charte d'expertise
très importante
il y a scène s'y prépare depuis
plusieurs années
il a organisé son travail avec la SN
pour rendre des avis dans les délais
compatibles avec les échéances de prise
de décision et ASN a déjà montré sa
capacité à anticiper à être réactif
c'est le cas pour les évaluations de
sûreté mis en oeuvre après l'accident de
Fukushima c'est aussi le cas pour la
prolongation de l'exploitation des
réacteurs de 900 MW au-delà de 40 ans
et pour laquelle nous avons rendu
analyse synthèse en mars 2020 en plein
confinement
au-delà de la sûreté nucléaire dont le
dôme au-delà de la sûreté nucléaire dans
le domaine de la santé l'évaluation des
technologies utilisant des rayonnements
ionisants pour le diagnostic et la
thérapeutique nécessite une vigilance
particulière pour s'assurer de la
balance bénéficerie pour les patients et
leur assurer des traitements sûr c'est
aussi notre rôle
cette nouvelle période suscite de fortes
inquiétudes chez les salariés de
l'Institut ce n'est pas sans impact sur
l'Institut dans un marché de l'emploi
tendu je vais être très vigilant pour
préserver l'attractivité de nos missions
il s'agit d'éviter une perte de
compétences en sûreté et en
radioprotection à court et moyen terme
je souhaite appeler pour conclure que la
cadence et la charge d'expertise et de
recherche pour les années à venir est
très importante
les équipes de l'IRSN que je remercie
pour leur engagement ce sont organisés
pour répondre à ces enjeux et être à la
hauteur de leur mission de service
public pour conclure en qualité de
dirigeants de ce bel établissement
public qu'il y a SN je travaille comme
me le demande la lettre de mission à
formuler des propositions de mise en
oeuvre de cette décision ainsi les
schémas qui pourraient être mis en place
dans le cadre de dans les schémas qui
pourraient être mis en place dans le
cadre de cette évolution il est
nécessaire de préserver les compétences
techniques et scientifiques pour être
capable de continuer à fournir une
expertise au plus haut niveau
d'assurer la séparation entre
l'expertudesseur y compris dans une
structure unique le soutenir d'une
manière ou d'une autre la pérennité de
la combinaison entre expertise et
recherche sur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les parlementaires je vous
remercie
bien merci à vous pour cette
présentation
la présentation notamment des enjeux
d'aujourd'hui et qui viendront également
dans dans le cadre de la réforme pour
mettre en perspective le projet de
transformation du système de contrôle de
la sûreté nucléaire nous allons à
présent entendre Michael Mangon qui est
donc historien du nucléaire
qui est donc historien du nucléaire
auteur d'une thèse de doctorat et donc
diverses publications sur ce sujet et
donc vous allez essayer en 5 10 minutes
si vous le souhaitez vous pouvez et bien
de nous éclairer sur la perspective de
de cette évolution
merci beaucoup pour cette introduction
donc bonjour à toutes et tous et merci
de m'avoir convié à cette audition je
suis donc Michael manjon chercheur
associé au laboratoire environnement
ville et société de l'Université de Lyon
et également consultant ma connaissance
du fonctionnement et de l'histoire du
système de contrôle et d'expertise vient
d'un travail de thèse en Sciences de
Gestion réalisé à mines par Itech et au
Laboratoire de sciences humaines et
sociales de l'IRSN un institut avec
lequel je travaille encore régulièrement
dernier point d'introduction je ne
connais aucun détail de ce projet de
réforme autre que la communication grand
public qui a été faite par le
gouvernement et je vais me concentrer
sur les aspects relatifs à la sûreté
nucléaire et aux installations civiles
donc pour démarrer je considère cette
nouvelle réforme du système de contrôle
et d'expertise comme une rupture majeure
au regard des temporalités longues
d'évolution de ce système pour étayer ce
constat on peut brièvement revenir sur
les choix qui ont présidé à la création
l'IRSN et de la SN ce qui peut éclairer
les risques et opportunités d'une
réforme de ce type c'est pendant les
années 1970 et au cœur du développement
du programme nucléaire français de
centrale EDF que sont créés un petit
service de quelques agents en charge de
contrôler la sûreté nucléaire au sein du
ministère de l'Industrie mais également
un institut en charge de l'expertise et
de la recherche en sûreté et
radioprotection au sein du CEA l'ipsm on
en a parlé déjà un petit peu si les
réacteurs français sont américains le
modèle d'expertise et de contrôle des
États-Unis est considéré comme trop
dirigiste trop dirigiste trop
réglementaire et il n'est pas retenu la
France poursuit plutôt une philosophie
plus souple basée avant tout sur le
dialogue technique entre experts
autorité et exploitant ce petit monde de
la sûreté nucléaire va expertiser et
contrôler les centrales nucléaires EDF
du plan Messmer et les suivantes à
marche forcée avec une réglementation
modeste dans des arènes discrètes et
fermées au public où la négociation et
la recherche de consensus entre
spécialistes sont alors la norme
la rapidité de développement du
programme nucléaire français mais aussi
l'accident de TRIMA Island en 1979 aux
États-Unis vont avoir pour conséquence
de consolider ce système français alors
que la commission américaine dite
keimani en charge d'analyser cette
accident va pointer le focus trop
réglementaire de l'Autorité de sûreté
américaine à contrario l'accident de
Tchernobyl en 1986 et notamment
l'affaire très médiatique du nuage
radioactif va fortement délégitimer le
système français qui va être associé au
lobby nucléaire dès 1987 lopex propose
la création d'une Agence nationale de
sécurité et d'information nucléaire
indépendant des pouvoirs publics pour
surveiller et réglementer les
installations et assurer la
communication auprès du public
cette idée ne sera pas directement
reprise mais le petit service de
contrôle au sein du ministère de
l'Industrie va grossir et évoluer dans
les années 90 alors que de son côté
l'IPSN va progressivement prendre son
indépendance au sein du CEA la fin des
années 1990 marque le point de départ de
la réorganisation la plus importante du
système avec la recommandation par
Jean-Yves le déo en 98 de créer un
expert public indépendant du CEA et une
autorité de sûreté forte et indépendante
du gouvernement précisant également que
construire un lien organique trop fort
entre l'Autorité de sûreté et le pôle
expertise reviendrait à limiter la
capacité d'expression de ce pôle
d'expertise la séparation entre
expertise scientifique et décision est
alors un élément clé de cette nouvelle
réforme qui est devenue aujourd'hui un
standard de bonne gouvernance des
risques la création de l'IRSN en 2002 et
de l'ASN en 2006 et donc l'achèvement
d'un long processus pour restaurer la
confiance et la réputation du contrôle
et de l'expertise aux yeux du public
évidemment ce nouveau système n'est pas
exempt de critique à la fin des années
2000 on envisage un au niveau du
nucléaire le chantier de le père de
Flamanville est en route on entrevoit un
second UPR à pont-lit mais également
d'exporter des réacteurs à travers le
monde un rapport sur l'avenir de la
filière nucléaire commandée par le
président Nicolas Sarkozy à François
rousse Lee ancien dirigeant d'EDF pointe
alors les excès ailes de la SN et
préconise que l'IRSN assure la diffusion
et la promotion des règles françaises à
l'international pour favoriser et en
support aux exploitants dans la vente de
leur réacteur l'accident de Fukushima en
2011 va mettre provisoirement un terme
assez volontés de changer le système
vers plus de souplesse et d'adéquation
avec le développement industriel le
système français est alors cité comme un
modèle de sûreté après Fukushima qui a
notamment montré les risques que
présente une collusion entre contrôleur
et contrôlée ce qui fut le cas au Japon
cette histoire nous apprend qu'il y a
deux tournants majeurs pour réformer un
système en réponse et en accompagnement
du développement d'un programme
nucléaire ou alors en réponse à un
accident ou une crise pour regagner la
légitimité et la confiance de la société
aujourd'hui nous entrons dans une ère
nouvelle au croisement entre
développement d'un programme nucléaire
en jeu de sûreté de légitimité et de
confiance pour cette réforme comment
l'interaction entre ces enjeux a-t-elle
été pensé imaginer quels sont les
impacts possibles de cette réforme sur
l'efficacité industrielle d'une part et
sur la sûreté d'autre part
je n'ai pas vu passer en tout cas
personnellement je n'ai pas vu passer
d'informations ou d'études sur ces
sujets enfin on a souvent tendance à se
focaliser sur les aspects techniques
pour analyser les accidents nucléaires
mais l'histoire nous montre que le
système et son fonctionnement sont une
cause profonde d'accident nucléaire
TRIMA Island Tchernobyl et Fukushima ont
des liens forts avec le fonctionnement
du système en place au moment de ses
accidents dans les pays concernés en ce
sens toute décision de réforme du
système à un impact direct ou indirect
sur la sûreté nucléaire et doit être
analysé en profondeur à ce stade
j'aurais donc du mal à dire si la sûreté
se retrouve renforcée ou non avec ce
projet de réforme dont je connais pas
les contours mais je vais terminer mon
propos en énumérant certains risques qui
sont finalement plutôt à ce stade des
questions sur les temporalités démarrer
un programme nucléaire sur un système en
mutation pas encore stabilisé
possiblement désorganisé présente un
risque en matière de sûreté notamment du
point de vue des facteurs humains et
organisationnels second point une partie
des travaux de recherche de l'URSS sont
difficilement dissociables de
l'expertise parfois les experts sont
eux-mêmes chercheurs le maintien d'un
modèle l'expertise se base sur une
science indépendante est aussi un
facteur de sûreté ce modèle sera-t-il
préservé concernant la séparation
expertise décision on a pu voir que
c'est un standard de bonne pratique au
niveau international et reconnu comme un
gage de sûreté quelle sera la forme
organisationnelle mais aussi et surtout
dans la pratique comment cette
séparation va-t-elle s'opérer dans la
nouvelle organisation on a parlé du
modèle de la NRC donc par exemple quels
sont les atouts et faiblesses de ce
modèle d'un point de vue de la
séparation expertise et décision
concernant le risque réputationnel la
longue route du système de pitcher
mobile a conféré un pouvoir et une
légitimité forte à la SN et à l'IRSN
auprès des citoyens qui s'est construits
sur le très long terme si un accident
nucléaire survit en France le système
sera de toute façon mis en cause il
devra alors être très solide pour
affronter cette épreuve et ne pas
refléter l'image d'un système dans le
but premier et de favoriser le
développement d'un nouveau programme
nucléaire enfin l'IRSN a construit un
lien fort avec la société et le tissu
associatif en matière de dialogue de
médiation scientifique et de
communication le maintien le maintien de
ce lien fort avec la société me semble
primordiale
ce lien est l'implication de la société
est aussi une demande forte du panel de
citoyens du débat public sur les
nouveaux réacteurs nucléaires de la
Commission nationale du débat public
merci beaucoup de votre attention
merci Monsieur manjon pour cette mise en
perspective je vais à présent donner la
parole à deux grands exploitants
d'installation nucléaires industrielles
que sont EDF et Orano qui vont
présenter leurs attentes vis-à-vis du
système de contrôle de la sûreté dont
ils sont aussi un maillon essentiel je
rappelle en effet que l'un des principes
fondateurs de la sûreté nucléaire est
que sa responsabilité première incombe à
l'exploitant je commence par donner la
parole à Bernard Sala directeur
recherche et développement et directeur
technique du groupe EDF
monsieur le Président messieurs les
parlementaires messieurs mesdames les
parlementaires merci de nous donner
l'occasion de nous exprimer sur ce sur
ce sujet extrêmement important
la sûreté je voudrais le dire en premier
et la priorité numéro 1
d'EDF exploitant nucléaire responsable
comme vous l'avez dit
nous avons pris bonne note des annonces
gouvernementales sur l'évolution de
l'organisation du contrôle de sûreté il
ne nous appartient pas
en tant que DF de nous positionner
vis-à-vis de l'organisation de ce
contrôle
il existe à l'international comme cela a
été évoqué plusieurs pratiques
différentes en matière d'organisation du
contrôle de la sûreté nucléaire qui ont
fait la preuve de leur bon
fonctionnement certaines sont très
proches de l'organisation envisagée on a
cité la NRC il peut y avoir aussi l'eau
nerf britannique l'âge du ferlandaise ou
l'autorité de sûreté même japonaise
récemment rénovée après Fukushima
à ce titre EDF est confiant que la très
haute qualité du contrôle de sûreté en
France sera maintenu voire accrue dans
le cadre de la nouvelle organisation
ce que je souhaiterais faire dans mes
propos suivants c'est vous donner
effectivement nos attentes comme vous
l'avez dit monsieur le Président
basé sur notre retour d'expérience
d'exploitation de nos réacteurs
pour assurer notre rôle d'exploitant
nucléaire responsable
EDF est attaché à une organisation du
contrôle de la sûreté qui soit
compétente et expérimenté techniquement
qui soit aussi impartial et indépendante
vis-à-vis de l'exploitant tant vis-à-vis
de l'exploitant que de l'ensemble des
parties prenantes quelle qu'elle soit
qui soit aussi porteuse de règles et de
pratiques techniques de contrôle qui
n'évoluent que dans un cadre fixé stable
notamment décennale orphénouveaux à
caractère exceptionnel de façon à donner
aux exploitants le temps nécessaire pour
une bonne appropriation industrielle et
humaine
qui soit à l'écoute des dispositions
prises à l'international par des
organisations de contrôle similaire et
réceptive à une homogénisation
internationale des meilleures pratiques
qui soient également transparente et
ouverte à des échanges techniques
fluides dans la phase d'instruction
préalablement à l'élaboration et la
validation de ses avis
publiée par un porte-parole unique
forte de ressources suffisante quelle
maîtrise lui permettant d'accéder à des
moyens d'expertise interne qui lui sont
propres ou externes avec lesquels elle
contractualiserait compte tenu des
besoins importants à venir
exploitation des réacteurs exploitation
long terme instruction des projets EPR
SMR voire d'autres types de réacteurs je
voudrais vous signaler pour vous donner
des ordres de grandeur de la charge de
travail à mener que le volume des
travaux d'une quatrième visite décennale
sur le palier 900 mégawatts représente 5
fois celui d'une visite de 3e décennale
je dis bien 5 fois
les investissements que nous faisons sur
notre parc nucléaire en exploitation ont
été multipliés par deux en disant
l'instruction de sûreté des réacteurs
EPR 2 et de New Ward est également
devant nous
il faudra également prévoir des
ressources pour les réacteurs innovants
à celles fondues
ou autre
il faut veiller à ce que cette question
de ressources ne constitue pas un goulet
d'étranglement au développement de ces
projets du fait d'une insuffisance de
moyens de l'autorité de contrôle
EDF reconnaît également l'apport du HCT
ISN le Haut Comité pour la transparence
et l'information sur la sécurité du
nucléaire pour garantir et promouvoir la
transparence de l'information sur la
sécurité du nucléaire
sur l'évolution des règles et des
pratiques techniques de contrôle de
sûreté et les activités de R&D qui ont
été évoquées
EDF souhaite que les règles les
pratiques techniques de contrôle restent
à la pointe technologique des meilleurs
pratiques disponibles
et que pour cela elle continue à évoluer
en renforçant ou des tarents les
exigences grand sous avancées techniques
apportées par le retour d'expérience
français internationale et par la R&D
pour autant les résultats de recherche
doivent acquérir la maturité
industrielle nécessaire avant d'être
intégré dans les règles techniques du
contrôle
le temps de la R&D est celui du contrôle
ne sont pas les mêmes
à ce titre EDF souhaite que l'autorité
de contrôle puisse commanditer les
activités de recherche quels jours
pertinentes et décidé du moment opportun
de leur intégration dans les règles et
pratiques de contrôle
à ce titre DF est favorable la
séparation de maîtrise d'ouvrage au sens
cahier des charges budget dédiées
calendrier de la recherche et des
activités de des activités de
réalisation de celle-ci aussi
l'évolution de l'organisation conduisant
à mobiliser préférentiellement les
compétences du CEA pour la réalisation
des activités de recherche nous paraît
aller dans la bonne direction
il est important aussi et ça a été dit
que l'ASN la nouvelle ASN puisse
disposer des ressources techniques
permettant de jouer son rôle de maîtrise
d'ouvrage de la recherche et de choisir
les acteurs avec laquelle la
contractualise
le CEA devra également clarifier la
séparation pardon entre les activités de
R&D faites pour le compte de
l'exploitant qui existe aujourd'hui
et celle faite pour le compte de la SN
pour éviter tout conflit d'intérêt
sur l'innovation
EDF constate l'émergence de nouvelles
innovations évolution technologique qui
pourrait avoir des impacts directs ou
indirects dans le nucléaire réciter le
digital l'intelligence artificielle la
fabrication additive les nouveaux
matériaux système passifs les nouveaux
petits réacteurs que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure
à ce titre EDF souhaite que la nouvelle
organisation du contrôle de sûreté
permettent d'intégrer ces innovations
EDF est favorable à la mise en place de
modalités progressives d'instructions de
sûreté
prototypage installation pilote
installation de série à l'instar de ce
qui existe dans d'autres industries de
pointe
sur les côtes de calcul
EDF considère avoir eu avec l'IRSN des
collaborations techniques fructueuses
sur la mise au point de codes de calcul
français élaboré et utiliser pour le
dimensionnement et la vérification des
installations ça rentrait trop dans la
technique cathares 3 5 claire magique
Saturne ils ont tous des petits noms
ce travail mené en commun optimise
l'utilisation de ressources rares et
permet une compréhension partagée des
phénomènes physiques à étudier
hors du cadre du contrôle de sûreté nous
recommandons ces coopérations sur les
codes de calcul soit préservés dans le
cadre de la nouvelle organisation
en conclusion EDF constate que la
nouvelle organisation envisagée pour le
contrôle de sûreté se rapproche de
schéma déjà pratiqué à l'international
et qui ont fait la preuve de leur succès
EDF considère que cette nouvelle
organisation est une opportunité pour
poursuivre et amplifier la démarche de
progrès lancer il y a plusieurs années
avec la création de l'Autorité de Sûreté
Nucléaire indépendante
et en lui donnant en complément
pleinement la maîtrise et le pilotage
des ressources consacrées au contrôle
à ce titre là prise en compte des
recommandations que je viens de faire
est une voix d'amélioration pour
exploiter en toute sûreté dans la durée
avec les meilleurs technologies
disponibles notre part de réacteur
existant et futur
EDF en tant qu'exploitant nucléaire
responsable est à la disposition le
mouvement venu les trois acteurs
désignés donc par la ministre la SN lire
scène de CEVA pour la déclinaison de la
nouvelle organisation je vous remercie
bien merci à vous pour ces explications
je laisse maintenant la parole à
Laurence Gazagne qui est directrice
sûreté santé sécurité et environnement
dorano monsieur le Président merci de
cette invitation et Orano et heureux de
participer à ce débat
à l'heure où la filière nucléaire se
projette dans des chantiers de
construction de futurs EPR et engage à
ces réflexions sur l'avenir des
installations de la valve du cycle la
question de la mise en oeuvre la sûreté
nucléaire en France se pose de façon
avec une acuité nouvelle le contexte
impose à la fois l'anticipation des
décisions préparer l'avenir et le besoin
de priorisation tout en maintenant au
niveau de contrôle de la sûreté de nos
installations
ceci implique de conserver une filière
nucléaire bien Grée et une autorité de
sûreté nucléaire organisée et efficace
il va de soi qui ne nous revient pas de
commenter l'organisation de son autorité
de contrôle
quel que soit le schéma d'organisation
retenu pour l'autorité
l'exploitant se mettra en ordre de
marche pour s'assurer que la sûreté et
la radioprojection ça a appliqué le plus
efficacement possible à ces
installations et notamment avec cette
notion de responsabilité d'exploitant
je ne rappellerai pas que pour arrano la
sûreté nucléaire est une priorité
absolue ça va de soi également elle est
assurée par l'ensemble des dispositions
prises en vue de prévenir les accidents
et dans limiter les effets donc tant
dans les domaines techniques
organisationnels et humains
relative à la conception à la
construction et l'exploitation jusqu'à
la mise à l'arrêt définitif et au
démantèlement de nos installations à
nucléaire de base ainsi qu'aux transport
des substances radioactives qu'il ne
faut pas oublier au sein du groupe nous
avons environ 1500 personnes qui sont
dédiées à ces activités de sûreté et de
radioprotection parmi 2017 000
collaborateurs que contient le groupe et
par ailleurs nous disposons également de
notre propre corps d'inspection nous
cultivons la transparence par une
communication régulière quand on interne
quand on externe avec nos parties
prenantes
regard des grands défis de la filière
nucléaire d'aujourd'hui de demain le
changement climatique les crises
sanitaires et géopolitiques la relance
du nucléaire Orano s'attache tout
particulièrement à garantir la sûreté
des installations et c'est bien la
responsabilité première de l'exploitant
nucléaire de veiller à ce que cet
objectif fondamental de sûreté soit
atteint dans tous les modes de
fonctionnement de l'installation c'est à
dire protéger les personnes et
l'environnement contre les effets
d'hommageables du rayonnement
ionisant et d'autres sources de danger
cet objectif repose sur trois grands
principes
le premier décliner une approche
proportionnelle aux enjeux il s'agit
pour l'exploitant dès la conception des
installations et pendant les examens de
périodique de concentrer les ressources
sur les sujets à enjeux et de maîtriser
les risques majeurs au niveau de sûreté
adapté cela implique un dialogue de
sûreté entretenu et approfondi avec
l'autorité pour une hiérarchisation des
sujets
le deuxième principe c'est d'appliquer
les exigences de sûreté avec rigueur au
plus près du terrain c'est-à-dire
traduire les rapports de sûreté en geste
opérationnel maîtrisé notre organisation
repose sur du personnel formé avec une
solide culture de sûreté travaillant
pour améliorer au quotidien la sûreté la
radioprotection des contrôles de dit de
premier niveau et comme je le disais un
corps d'inspecteur interne à Orano le
troisième enjeu est d'anticiper les
conditions de la poursuite du
fonctionnement du cycle en sûreté
pour permettre l'atteinte de ses
objectifs exploitant a besoin d'une
stabilisation des référentiels et d'une
simplification des procédures qui sont
des facteurs clés de succès
quelles sont les défis spécifiques à
Orano vous les connaissez dans ce
contexte il y a l'extension d'usine
d'enrichissement pour lequel la
concertation a démarré sur le Tricastin
la pérennisation du traitement recyclage
des combustibles
assuré par les usines de lag et de Melox
tout en assurant la gestion des passifs
et le démantèlement de nos installations
pour préparer le futur sur la base du
retour d'expérience des années de
fonctionnement des installations la
filière aura développé des outils
exploitables maintenables qui délivre en
temps et en heure et en sûreté ceci
suppose également des études techniques
et des dossiers nombreux à élaborés par
l'exploitant et à instruire par
l'autorité
tout cela implique un développement
d'approche innovantes également en
termes de techniques de construction par
exemple et de méthodes telles que les
codes de calcul dont dont nous parlions
le renforcement d'une approche
opérationnelle une vision partagée et
hiérarchisée des objectifs de sûreté de
radioprotection le maintien et le
développement des compétences chez
l'exploitant mais aussi son autorité et
la capacité collective à inscrire
rapidement et efficacement les dossiers
je vous remercie
bien merci à vous pour cette
contribution j'ai maintenant le plaisir
de donner la parole à l'un de mes
illustres prédécesseurs Claude Biraud
qui revient dans ses murs pour porter la
voix cette fois-ci d'une instance de
concertation et de dialogue qui est
central dans le système de contrôle de
la Sûreté Nucléaire le Haut Comité pour
la transparence et l'information de la
sécurité nucléaire cher Claude vous avez
la parole
merci monsieur le Président je voudrais
d'abord dire que je n'exprimerai pas la
vie globale du Haut comité qui est
composé de cette
cette partie et qu'il faut un accord
entre les parties pour donner un avis
puisqu'il a pas eu un statué là-dessus
mais j'ai pu échanger avec la présidente
et je dois vous dire en préambule que
j'ai déjà une relation assez
particulière avec la SN avec l'IRSN avec
l'IRSN d'abord parce que j'ai fait
partie au tout début alors qu'il était
encore IPSN d'un comité de préfiguration
de ce qui aurait été un conseil
d'administration d'un IPSN indépendant
d'autre part en 2002 lorsque la loi
instaurée l'IRSN le gouvernement de
l'époque avait prévu de séparer les
activités civiles des activités
militaires de l'URSS j'avais évidemment
défendu le point de vue inverse avec
beaucoup de convictions et de véhémence
et je puis vous dire que Madame Toubiana
qui était la conseillère environnement
du Premier ministre m'avait recontacté
et ainsi que Robert Gallet à la demande
du Premier ministre pour savoir comment
et voir la structure définitive de
l'IRSN
et la semaine suivante j'ai croisé
Robert Gallet qui m'a dit Madame Tubiana
t'a appelé elle m'a dit que nous avions
la même position
c'est-à-dire que il fallait bien que les
activités militaires soient restent à
l'IRSN avec un directeur adjoint chargé
des activités militaires donc ça nous
ramène à la proposition d'aujourd'hui
moi je suis un peu surpris parce que la
loi qui a créé l'ASN dit que ces membres
ne reçoivent ni ne sollicite
d'instruction d'aucune autorité or la
demande qu'il aurait faite pour fin
février me semble être d'abord une
instruction avec la SN
l'Office Parlementaire entretenu des
liens de confiance pendant tout le temps
à des relations de proximité et c'est
très bien qu'il y a cette relation entre
l'Autorité de sûreté et le Parlement
l'organisation qui est prévue
me paraît
receler une méconnaissance grave de
l'organisation de la sûreté nucléaire
la Sûreté Nucléaire ce n'est pas un
nirvana que l'on atteint un jour en
disant ça y est j'ai atteint la Sûreté
Nucléaire la sûreté nucléaire c'est un
combat de tous les jours
et lorsque je rencontrais les
organisations syndicales
elle me disait nous sommes nous les
travailleurs du nucléaire d'ailleurs
monsieur le Président vous auriez
peut-être pu aussi invité les
organisations syndicales à s'exprimer et
les travailleurs du nucléaire ce ne sont
pas des travailleurs comme les autres
et la sûreté nucléaire elle se nourrit
de quoi elle se nourrit de la
confrontation entre l'expertise la
recherche l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire
et c'est de cette confrontation là que
va naître tous les jours la Sûreté
Nucléaire on ne l'atteint pas une fois
pour toutes
elles se fondent sur la recherche et
elle se nourrit de la recherche et
aujourd'hui si la recherche devait
partir au CEA ça me paraîtrait quelque
chose d'extrêmement grave pourquoi parce
que
on serait dans une sorte de confusion
des genres
confusion des gens si le parce que
l'Autorité de sûreté elle va elle a
aussi autorité sur les installations du
CEA or comment juger de la sûreté d'une
nouvelle installation si la recherche
sur laquelle ça peut ira son expertise
et faite au seva ça me paraît être une
confusion des gens qui est fortement
préjudiciable à l'organisation même de
la sûreté
et
l'autre chose qui me paraît important
le nucléaire aujourd'hui a un certain
regain d'intérêt compte tenu de la crise
énergétique
il y a une confiance du public qui a été
difficile à obtenir parce que il y a 40
ans on disait c'est tous les mêmes
le gouvernement
le ministère de l'Industrie ce qu'on
appelait le zinzin
l'IPSN le CEA c'est les mêmes
EDF on ne peut pas avoir confiance
tout le travail de toutes ces années
sous l'impulsion de l'office
parlementaire et d'autres a été de
séparer les fonctions d'expertise de
recherche et de régulation
administrative aujourd'hui imaginez une
installation de recherche du CEA sur
laquelle la SN doit se proposer
prononcer
elle va faire appel à ses experts ou
est-ce qu'elle a le service de recherche
qui pourra la conseiller puisqu'elle
n'aura plus de recherche elle va la
prendre au CEA il va être jugé partie et
ça c'est un recul
que vous ne mesurez pas mais c'est un
recul de 40 ans et je crois qu'il ne
faut pas rompre brutalement
casser cette confiance qui au fil du
temps c'est nouer sur l'organisation
actuelle
l'IRSN a aussi un rôle important
vis-à-vis de la société civile avec le
Conseil d'orientation de la recherche
qui regroupe avec l'interface société
scientifique pour co-construire un
certain nombre de choses si tout cela
disparaît c'est la confiance qui va
disparaître et la suspicion qui va
nourrir à nouveau le doute chez nos
concitoyens donc il faudrait pas qu'on
voulant aller vite on se heurte ensuite
à une opposition de plus en plus
véhémente et de plus en plus forte parce
que cela serait contre-productif chacun
sait ici ce que cela veut dire mais au
véritable sens c'est-à-dire contre
l'intérêt et contre la marche normale
d'une d'un système de recherche
j'ai bien connu la NRC
la NRC était un
être extrêmement lourd
on ne pouvait pas rencontrer les
commissaires ensemble on ne pouvait pas
les rencontrer deux par deux
il fallait rencontrer individuellement
et la seule fois où j'ai pu les voir
quatre sur cinq c'est dans un déjeuner
où le président Richard mézerve m'avait
invité donc on est toujours dans ce
système administratif il y a quelque
chose qui marche bien je pense que la
fluidité marche il n'est peut-être pas
nécessaire de tout casser
bien merci
chers collègues pour
cette expression qui elle mérite d'être
clair
les commissions locales d'information
sont une autre composante importante
dans notre système de contrôle de la
sûreté et dans cette perspective je
laisse la parole à Jean-Claude delalombe
qui est président de l'Association
nationale des comités et commissions
locales d'information
merci monsieur le Président je vous
remercie de vous de nous avoir convié à
cette audition publique en tant que
Fédération nationale des 35 commissions
locales d'information les clients des
instances qui œuvrent depuis 40 ans et
que la loi de 2006 sur la transparence
puis celle de 2015 sur la transition
énergétique ont conforté dans leur
mission et dans leur rôle pour la bonne
information de tous et du public qui
nous suit compte tenu du temps qui m'est
alloué je souhaiterais que vous
acceptiez monsieur le Président que
l'oncle verse à cette réunion trois
documents qui explique nos
interrogations sur le projet qui nous
réunit aujourd'hui
le premier du 15 avril 2014 est un
rapport cossigné de la SN et de l'IRSN
il précise je cite le dispositif de
contrôle des activités nucléaires
civiles repose sur un dispositif dual
asnirsn dont l'efficacité en matière de
gouvernance des risques et démontrer
c'était pas il y a pas si longtemps il
enchaîne également je cite que la
principale force du dispositif dual
réside dans le fait que le poids de la
décision ne pèse pas sur l'Institut qui
est en charge de l'expertise et de la
Recherche associée et il souligne
l'importance fondamentale de la
recherche comme un déterminant majeur de
la qualité de l'expertise de l'IRSN le
deuxième document du 2 juin 2016 un peu
plus proche également qu'aux signé de la
SN et de l'IRSN qui plébiscite le
nouveau de nouveau le système dual en
insistant sur les conséquences négatives
d'une possible mise en concurrence de la
fonction d'évaluation technique des
risques nucléaires et radiologiques en
cas de fusion de l'IRSN avec la SN 2016
le troisième du 11 mai 2015 qui fait
suite aux entretiens que l'ampli et
personnellement que
j'ai rencontré et que nous avons eu sur
le financement le renforcement de la
sûreté nucléaire dans le cadre d'une
mission décidée par le ministre des
Finances et la ministre de
l'Environnement de l'époque
l'ankli rappelait notamment son
attachement à l'accès du public à
l'expertise institutionnelle et à son
indépendance précisant que
l'indépendance dans l'expertise serait
perçue par le public comme une raison
suffisante de défiance ce qu'a dit
Claude Biron l'anky alerté enfin est
déjà sur l'inéficience des procédures
précipitées ce que nous pensons encore
aujourd'hui je souhaite souligner trois
points essentiels
quelle urgence y a-t-il aujourd'hui à
devoir remettre sous 15 jours au
gouvernement les premières mesures
législatives visant à mettre en oeuvre
ses évolutions lorsqu’un
organisationnelles le système dual
plébiscité unanimement depuis 2014 et
2016 a-t-il été remis en cause par
quiconque
a-t-il montré des faiblesses jusqu'à
leur imperceptibles
a-t-il failli à son objectif d'un
système d'expertise et de contrôle
indépendant complémentaires et ultra
robuste à ma connaissance non en 2014 la
Cour des comptes allait considérée je
cite que la fusion était inappropriée et
inefficace et qu'il fallait suivre les
propositions conjoines de la SN et de
l'IRSN de consolidation du dispositif
dual qui lui-même était le résultat des
préconisations de l'OPEX
je rappelle que le rapport remis au
gouvernement en 2015 qui proposait la
fusion des deux institutions avaient été
définitivement écartés par le Parlement
et l'exécutif
y a-t-il aujourd'hui une étude d'un parc
qui conformerait la décision du Conseil
de politique nucléaire et qui aurait
examiné les conséquences positives et ou
négatives du changement de
l'organisation actuelle de la sûreté ou
qui irait à l'encontre des décisions de
2014 et de 2016 que j'ai pu citer
précédemment à ma connaissance non
transférer la recherche au CEA quel que
soit sa compétence nous nous conduit-ils
pas un risque de fermeture de l'accès
aux informations à la société civile que
nous connaissons par ailleurs avec le
CEA
enfin les clients et l'enclient ne
serait pas ce qu'elles sont aujourd'hui
sans les efforts et les initiatives
différentes et complémentaires
développer à la fois par la SN et par
l'IRSN pour développer la compétence de
nos membres sur les questions du
nucléaire
l'expertise citoyenne est devenue une
réalité
reconnue par les acteurs du nucléaire et
c'est grâce à ce dispositif dual cette
expertise citoyenne challenge en quelque
sorte la sûreté mais aussi la recherche
à une époque où les organismes
institutionnels sont en pleine crise de
confiance avec leurs administrés
l'ouverture de l'IRSN à la société
civile est un axe fort pour renforcer la
cohésion des acteurs pour co-construire
les décisions dans le domaine sensible
et tabou que nous connaissons dans la
filière nucléaire ceci ne risque-t-il
pas de disparaître dans la nouvelle
elle doit se faire sereinement en posant
les arguments positifs et négatifs et en
examinant toutes les conséquences d'un
changement et ceci sous le contrôle du
Parlement dans la responsabilité est
très importante à mes yeux en ce sens je
me permets de vous suggérer que soit
lancée pourquoi pas sous l'égide de
l'OPEX une forme d'État généraux de la
sûreté
il s'agirait d'examiner l'organisation
actuelle de la sûreté de sa recherche de
son expertise de son contrôle mais aussi
d'examiner les synergies entre les
acteurs et enfin de rechercher pourquoi
pas les vecteurs les plus appropriés
pour fluidifier s'il le faut ou pour
réorganiser le système merci de votre
attention
je vous remercie pour votre intervention
simplement je voudrais en préambule dire
que l'OPEX est évidemment toujours
l'acteur principal et restera l'acteur
principal du Parlement sur les enjeux de
sûreté nucléaires nous avons eu
d'ailleurs il y a encore quelques
semaines l'occasion
d'échanger de vous inviter leur d'une
audition sur la corrosion sous
contrainte c'est si je puis dire
l'engagement ou la thématique qui est
sûrement la plus abordée au sein de
l'office et ce depuis sa création et
c'est pourquoi nous nous devions
aujourd'hui et bien de pouvoir toutes et
tous vous auditionnez dans le cadre de
cette réforme annoncée par le ministère
de la transition énergétique
nous allons à présent ouvrir le débat et
je suis sûr que beaucoup de nos
collègues parlementaires ont des
questions à poser j'ai reçu des
premières demandes et n'hésitez pas
également à me solliciter pour demander
la parole je laisse la parole à Gérard
le seul
merci président merci madame messieurs
pour vos propos je me permettrai de
poursuivre le débat en posant trois
questions que l'on pourrait résumer
finalement en pourquoi pourquoi
première question de la sûreté nucléaire
et de la radioprotection le statut de la
SN est fixé par la loi de 2006 dites loi
transparence
après des débats fructus au Parlement et
une approbation quasi unanime des
parlementaires depuis cette date la SN
et les RSN ont fait preuve de leurs
compétences et de leur transparence et
dans les circonstances dramatiques liées
à focushima dans le contrôle de au
quotidien du nucléaire en France le père
de Flamanville les corrosion sous
contrainte le système français de
contrôle du nucléaire a prouvé sa
compétence son indépendance et sa
transparence alors pourquoi remettre en
cause brutalement ou soudainement le
fonctionnement d'une équipe qui a
globalement gagné la confiance des
Français quand ça a été rappelé tout à
l'heure dans un contexte où la France a
cruellement besoin d'elle pourquoi les
fusions d'organisation même réussi son
boulimiques en énergie et crée des
angoisses légitimes vous en avez évoqué
quelques-unes des dysfonctionnements
alors pourquoi les réponses données par
la ministre à la commission du
développement durable récemment n'ont
pas donné les explications que le
Parlement est en droit d'attendre donc
merci pour vos précisions sur ce point
deuxième question si vous me le
permettez deuxième salve
le président de la SN le système dual
qui a été évoqué à nos entreprises tout
à l'heure le système dual donc qui est
basé sur deux organismes indépendants à
SN et RSN va être donc fusionnée en tout
cas c'est le projet vous avez dit dans
la presse récemment qu'un autre système
dual allait être mis en place au sein de
l'ASN en différents sur l'instruction
qui serait le fait de vos services et la
décision qui serait le fait du collège
quelle garantie pouvez-vous donner en
termes d'indépendance des deux processus
pour qu'il puisse continuer à être
qualifiés de dual la loi transparence de
2006 a consacré le développement de la
transparence c'est de la décision de la
participation des citoyens et des
parties prenantes donc à cette décision
l'ASM mais aussi et surtout l'IRSN ce
sont largement impliqués dans ce
processus légitime inscrit dans la loi
comment comptez-vous le maintenir et
surtout de faire progresser dans un
contexte ou une contrainte forte semble
être l'accélération des procédures peut
être d'ailleurs au détriment de la
concertation et transparence je suis à
titre personnel très dubitatif sur le
gain de temps réel et la qualité de la
décision quand on simplifie par trop les
procédures et puis dernière question si
vous me le permettez à EDF vous avez
évoqué monsieur récemment le passage
enfin votre établissement a évoqué
récemment le passage jusqu'à 80 ans de
la durée de vie des réacteurs ce qui
peut apparaître surprenant voire
inadapté à la réglementation laquelle
prévoit des réexamens de sûreté tous les
10 ans alors j'aimerais beaucoup que des
f exploitant responsable et prévoyant
puisse indiquer à la représentation
nationale l'espérance de vie réacteur
par réacteur de son parc j'ai bien
compris que la cuve est par définition
dimensionnante pour la vie du réacteur
quel être quel est votre visibilité sur
ce point crucial pour la desserte
énergétique de notre pays je vous
remercie pardonnez-moi d'avoir été un
peu long cher président
andrick Davy alors bonjour à tous et
tous merci d'abord pour vos
éclaircissements sur les enjeux les liés
à la sécurité nucléaire je rêve juste
effectivement que les représentants des
travailleurs des travailleurs du
nucléaire n'est pas été invités
peut-être une prochaine audition ce
serait intéressant voilà alors j'ai une
série de questions et de commentaires
vous connaissez la position du groupe
elle est finie UPS nous sommes pour une
sortie évidemment de l'énergie nucléaire
et porter plutôt nos efforts sur la
sobriété énergétique néanmoins quel que
soit nos choix stratégiques concernant
l'énergie nous aurons besoin encore
longtemps de recherche dans le domaine
du nucléaire deux métiers dans le
secteur du nucléaire pour organiser la
transition et surtout d'une organisation
de contrôle concernant la sûreté
nucléaire alors quel est le problème
structurel du nucléaire c'est qu'en cas
d'accident les conséquences peut-être
gravissimes ce qui est un peu différent
avec les énergies renouvelables le
président de la SN déclarait en 2022 un
accident nucléaire est toujours possible
et ceux qui prétendraient le contraire
prennent une grande responsabilité il y
a donc toujours eu une suspicion dans
notre pays sur la transparence
concernant les risques associés au
nucléaires donc moi je suis assez étonné
car chambouler notre système dual de
contrôle de sûreté faire et supprimer
l'IRSN alors que le gouvernement veut
relancer la filière est très surprenant
d'un point de vue d'un point de vue
temporalité nous devons d'abord je
l'estime une étude d'impact où est le
rapport où sont les rapports qui mettrai
en lumière le dysfonctionnement dans
l'organisation dual actuel et cette
restructuration ne va-t-elle pas changer
notre doctrine vis-à-vis de la sûreté
d'une doctrine déterministe à une
doctrine un peu plus probabiliste pour
lever les obstacles on comprend bien au
développement du nucléaire et ce au
détriment de notre sûreté collective
enfin que vont devenir les 1700 salariés
de l'Institut Sintel organisation avait
lieu nous devons surtout s'assurer d'un
indépendance de ceux qui contrôlent la
sûreté et le décideur ce que vous avez
rappelé monsieur Jean-Christophe Niel et
ce qui me semble contradictoire avec la
fusion annoncée mais vous avez peut-être
mauvais expliquer ça Michael Mangeot a
aussi rappelé que cette séparation
expertise décision est égale de bonne
gouvernance du système de sûreté et que
les accidents passés étaient toujours
liés à des défaillances du système de
sûreté
les Français ne risquent-ils pas
d'interpréter cette réorganisation comme
la volonté de casser le thermomètre qui
régulièrement nous informe des
dysfonctionnements dans le secteur du
nucléaire et vous réez compris j'ai
partage beaucoup le point de vue de
Claude Biraud et en ce qui me concerne
et après les auditions je ne peux que
recommander un moratoire sur cette
réorganisation et le lancement d'un
grand débat sur la question de la sûreté
nucléaire
merci
Stéphane piennois
merci monsieur le président
il permettrait d'abord de livrer
quelques mots sur la sur la méthode qui
est utilisée par le gouvernement je fais
partie de ceux je crois de tous ceux qui
ont été très surpris par les annonces du
gouvernement fait en catimini j'ai envie
de dire au détour d'une d'une
conversation je trouve que ce sujet
mérite bien mieux qu'une qu'une
interpellation au détour d'un couloir et
je trouve que cette méthode
met déjà une forme de suspicion sur sur
le procédé ceci étant dit il appartient
bien évidemment au gouvernement de
définir la politique les politiques
publiques dont il a la charge s'agissant
de la Sûreté Nucléaire évidemment que la
ministre panière nuager à la
responsabilité de
éventuellement
réinterroger le modèle de notre du
contrôle de notre sûreté nucléaire
ça a été dit d'ailleurs cette
organisation est le fruit d'une
évolution assez ancienne pour certains
50 ans c'est en fait assez récent
puisque les dernières décisions date de
2002 de 2006 donc on a une organisation
qui est en fait
qui date de 15 ans d'une quinzaine
d'années c'est relativement court à
l'échelle d'une industrie et encore plus
d'une industrie telle que l'industrie
nucléaire donc ce que je veux dire c'est
que bien sûr que le gouvernement à la
main pour définir une nouvelle
éventuellement une nouvelle organisation
mais nous avons aussi la légitimité
légitimité de nous interroger sur le
modèle actuel qui est donc le fruit de
cette évolution mais le fruit de
décision récente c'est le travaux de
contrôle des parlementaires qui est qui
s'illustre de la manière de cette
manière je voudrais rappeler d'ailleurs
au passage que bien peu de parlementaire
c'est meuf de
du piétinement en fait de la loi puisque
la loi de 2006 par exemple prévoit la
fermeture du cycle c'est toujours
inscrit dans nos dans nos textes de loi
l'arrêt du programme Astrid sur les réac
de nouvelles générations de recteurs à
deux trois rapides mais à mal cette
fermeture du cycle qui est
issue de la loi de 2006 je m'étonne que
ça ne n'émeve pas plus que ça un certain
nombre de parlementaires pour en revenir
au sujet je serai évidemment d'accord
avec tous ceux qui diront qu'il est
nécessité de maintenir un niveau de
sûreté optimal qui fait la force de
notre industrie nucléaire si si souvent
et sous lourdement mise à mal par
d'autres décisions politiques je
voudrais savoir sur les sur les missions
qui ont été confiées aux trois parties
principales de cette de cette affaire à
savoir
l'IRSN la SN et le CEA si les parties
donc ont déjà envisagé des évolutions
puisque telle est l'intention du
gouvernement de vous confier cette cette
initiative en définitive
quels sont éventes d'éventuelles
doublons qui ont été identifiés par
chacun d'entre vous et je pensais
évidemment à lire SN et la SN des
optimisations des évolutions qui
seraient favorables et qui contribuerait
à maintenir ce niveau de sûreté auquel
nous sommes tous évidemment très
attachés sur la diffusion de des
expertises quels engagements peut
prendre aujourd'hui l'ASN sur une une
transparence qui est elle aussi inscrite
dans la loi avec dans la loi de 2006
comment l'ASN envisage cette cette
évolution
en conclusion et pour ne pas être trop
long monsieur le Président je voudrais
dire quand même que ce le texte nous
avons eu un texte d'accélération de
construction de nouveaux réacteurs
nucléaires à l'Assemblée enfin au Sénat
d'abord et prochainement à l'Assemblée
nationale je trouve vraiment regrettable
qu'on n'est pas profité de ce texte en
amont c'est un projet de loi donc avec
une étude d'impact qu'on n'est pas
profité de cette occasion pour évaluer
dans l'étude d'impact du projet de loi
une éventuelle fusion ça c'est vraiment
pour en revenir sur la méthode je vous
remercie
je vous propose de que les intervenants
puissent répondre au premier question et
ensuite il y aura j'ai pris les autres
intervenants ne vous inquiétez pas
peut-être monsieur le Président de l'ASM
merci merci de monsieur le Président
merci
mesdames et Messieurs les parlementaires
aussi de vos questions alors moi
j'insisterai essentiellement sur trois
points qui me semblent avoir été évoqué
à plusieurs reprises à la fois dans les
interventions et dans vos premières
questions premier sujet sur lequel je
veux intervenir parce qu'on voit que
c'est au cœur de notre discussion c'est
la question de du système dit dual je le
mets entre guillemets je pense qu'il
faut il faut que l'on regarde les choses
de manière plus nuancée que ce que l'on
peut penser être la réalité en fait
comment se passe la prise de décision de
l'Autorité de sûreté et quel est le
processus qui face à un sujet nous
conduit à demander une expertise parfois
demander des avis à l'extérieur nous
avons des groupes permanents d'experts
qui donnent des avis et ensuite à
débattre des différents avis des
différents rapports au sein d'un collège
qui n'a pas été impliqué dans les étapes
précédentes et qui prend une décision
d'abord je voudrais nuancer le premier
point c'est que ce processus dit
d'expertise en amont et déjà pluriel
c'est-à-dire qu'on ne il n'y a pas
l'IRSN qui fait son expertise
indépendamment de la SN indépendamment
des exploitants nous sommes tous
ensemble certes la commande est à IRSN
le rapport d'expertise sera celui de
l'URSS mais avant de se prononcer avant
de démettre un avis d'expertise encore
faut-il aller au fond du sujet et
discuter à la fois avec l'exploitant ça
a été rappelé l'importance du dialogue
technique avec les exploitants et avec
les équipes de l'ASM qui ont aussi une
expertise donc le processus n'est pas
aussi cloisonné qu'on pourrait penser il
y a déjà dans l'étape de d'expertise
réalisée par l'IRSN des échanges ensuite
dire que c'est le modèle français unique
ce n'est pas vrai il y a des certaines
agences je pense notamment à landeces
qui a structurellement dans ses missions
et c'est inscrit dans ses missions à la
fois la charge de réaliser des
expertises et de prendre des décisions
ça existe déjà donc c'est pas un modèle
qui qui serait totalement nouveau alors
bien sûr c'est ciblé sur quelques mais
ça existe ensuite nous ASN nous avons
également à l'intérieur de la set un
service d'expertise pour des sujets qui
sont très importants très ciblées
notamment c'est tous les équipements
sous pression de la chaudière nucléaire
c'est la direction des équipements sous
pression de l'ASN qui mène expertise en
relation étroite avec l'IRSN donc
voyez-vous le panorama est plus nuancé
que l'on ce que l'on pourrait dire il
faut à mon avis faire attention devant
des affirmations qui peuvent être
différentes alors bien évidemment à
l'étranger lorsque il y a plusieurs
états plusieurs pays dans lesquels il y
a les compétences d'expertise et de
décision sont rassemblées il y a des
processus qui sont définis alors je
reviens sur votre question ce député
évidemment quel serait qu'elle pourrait
être un schéma d'une certaine manière
donc comme je l'ai dit aujourd'hui nous
avons déjà une séparation qui existe
entre la phase amont qui est la phase de
dialogue technique d'expertise de
relation avec l'exploitant avec l'IRSN
et puis la phase avale qui est la phase
de décision la loi prévoit que les
décisions de l'Autorité de sûreté
nucléaire sont du ressort exclusif de
son collège c'est le collège qui décide
et il décide sur quelle base il décide
sur la base de d'un rapport qui lui est
présenté de propositions qui lui sont
faites et qui ont été élaborés dans le
processus d'expertise en amont il n'y a
pas de relation entre les membres du
collège et les services jusqu'à la
présentation du sujet au collège donc
c'est un modèle qui qui correspond
auproux à ce qui est mis en place dans
les autorités indépendantes à l'étranger
et c'est un modèle qui bien évidemment
dans l'hypothèse ou la réforme qui est
présentée irrés à son terme serait à
consolider à définir à préciser mais il
y aura bien toujours une séparation
entre la montre et la valve de la prise
de décision et c'est important en termes
de responsabilité bien évidemment tout à
fait tout à fait
ensuite je sur le je voudrais intervenir
sur le sujet de la transparence et le
sujet de la relation avec le public
comme ça a été très bien dit par le
président de l'ampli en fait nous
travaillons déjà ensemble
ISSN et s.n dans toutes les relations
avec le réseau des clients
avec le Haut Comité avec les parties
prenantes je reçois moi-même
régulièrement les ONG donc il n'y a pas
de il y a pas d'un côté une entité qui
serait ouverte à la société relation
avec les parties prenantes et de l'autre
côté une entité qui ne serait moins ce
n'est pas comme ça que ça se passe dans
la vraie vie nous avons parfois une fois
de les choses ensemble il y a toute une
série d'innovations qui ont été faites
certaines dernières années en termes de
participation du public d'associations
du public dans le processus même
d'instruction et de décision je pense
notamment au quatrième visite décennale
ou réglementairement il n'y a pas
d'obligation d'associer les publics et
nous l'avons fait avec le haut cohabiter
et nous l'avons fait en liaison avec les
clients on fait des webinaires sur la
CSC la même chose donc il y a déjà
beaucoup de choses qui se font de part
et d'autre qui se font ensemble et dans
la nouvelle structure si bien sûr la
réforme était mise en place tout cela
sera maintenu voire consolider il y a
aucune raison que ça disparaisse la
relation avec la société civile toute la
le travail de dialogue technique restera
il y a pas d'obligation ou
d'interdiction à ce que ça soit porté
par l'essai donc je pense que ça c'est
important en termes de transparence je
reviens également sur le processus il y
a d'autres experts que nous avons pas
cité qui sont aujourd'hui consultés au
moment où nous prenons la décision avant
de prendre la décision c'est notamment
une des groupes permanents d'experts qui
réunissent des experts extérieurs qui
réunissent des représentants
scientifiques du monde de la recherche
des anciens exploitants etc donc sur des
sujets les plus sensibles à l'issue de
l'instruction
il y a un groupe permanent d'experts qui
est sollicité pour donner un avis qui
est du public qui est rendu public avant
même que nous prenions une décision je
parlerai d'un exemple qui je pense est
important chacun a encore en tête
lorsque l'ASM a pris la décision qui
était lourde de conséquences et ensuite
tout à fait conscient de demander à EDF
de réparer les soudures de traverser
enceinte de l'EPR il y avait eu un
travail d'expertise en amont il y avait
eu dans lequel le la direction des
équipements sous pression de la snavait
joué un rôle majeur parce que c'était
nous qui portions le sujet en tant que
compétent dans le domaine des
équipements sous pression du circuit
primaire principal enfin de la chaudière
nucléaire pardon bien évidemment les
trois relations avec l'URSS il y avait
une présentation au groupe permanent
distinct de tout cela
sur les équipements sous pression et la
vie avait été rendue publique qui était
un avis qui disait je le résume
les conditions enfin la situation est
telle que la clause d'exclusion de
rupture qui était l'élément fondamental
qui permettait de justifier de
d'une certaine manière on accepte la
conception pardon qui avait été faite
par EDF cette clause n'était pas
maintenue
compte tenu des déficiences des défauts
qu'il y avait été découverts au moment
de la construction donc il y a bien eu
un avis extérieur et cet avis extérieur
restera et il sera publique en termes de
transparence c'est important donc je dis
il faut faire attention de ne pas être
trop schématique de ne pas considérer
qu'il y a d'un côté et une instruction
et de l'autre côté une décision que les
gens ne se parlent pas ne sont pas en
contact avec les exploitants ils ne
prennent pas d'avis extérieure etc ce
n'est pas le cas ce n'est pas le cas et
en termes de transparence je rappelle
que nous publions toutes les lettres de
suite d'inspection il y a déjà beaucoup
de situations de transparence d'acte de
transparence ça sera maintenu à la
limite on peut le mettre dans la loi
pour que ça soit quelque chose d'inscrit
en dur puisque aujourd'hui c'est une
pratique qui ne résume d'aucune décision
réglementaire ou législative moi je
pense que voilà moi je crois que si bien
évidemment le processus se poursuit et
je pense que c'est important qu'il le
soit je pense que il ne faut pas il y a
des choses à inventer d'une certaine
manière mais les meilleures choses de
part et d'autre on les conservera il
faudra les conserver je terminerai sur
sur le sujet
qui est finalement celui de
davantage davantage qui serait de mon
point de vue tout à fait perceptible de
la mise en place d'une telle
organisation tout d'abord il y a une
situation qui est
attaché énormément d'importance c'est
celle de la capacité globale à appuyer
le gouvernement en situation d'urgence
aujourd'hui nous avons un système qui
est d'une certaine manière fractionnelle
l'expertise IRSN en matière de gestion
des situations de crise d'outils à la
prévision et être reconnu mondialement
la SNA également bien évidemment un
centre de crise en situation de crise
aujourd'hui le système tel qu'il est
prévu il reste scène établit au vu des
informations dont elle dispose et du
dialogue avec l'expattant un diagnostic
de la situation et ce projette sur les
événements ce qui pourrait se produire à
l'avenir cette le résultat de cette
expertise et est donné à l'ASM et l'ASN
est en contact avec le gouvernement pour
proposer des recommandations en matière
de gestion de crise ce système n'est pas
réaliste en situation de crise il faut
aller plus vite il faut que les équipes
soient totalement intégrées le fait
d'avoir un système nouveau de mon point
de vue permettrait de répondre à cette
situation d'avoir une approche mieux
intégrée de la gestion des situations de
crise
voilà ce que je voulais dire en premier
est-ce que peut-être d'autres
intervenants qui voulaient
sur le sur le le personnel je voulais en
profiter si vous me donnez la parole
pour pour rappeler que l'obsession des
gens de l'Institut c'est la sûreté
nucléaire à la radioproduction c'est
vraiment leur mission c'est des gens de
mission en fait
sur concernant les personnes les lettres
de mission indique évidemment que que
dans le processus mis en oeuvre leurs
conditions de travail leur rémunération
seront maintenues et en tant que
dirigeant de l'établissement ce sera
évidemment une de mes procuations
majeures l'évolution de ce type c'est
évident que c'est c'est d'ailleurs bien
pour tout simplement pour les personnes
parce qu'il y a pas raison qu'elle soit
maltraitées mais plus fondamentalement
encore parce que il faut c'est les
points il faut avoir le maintien des
compétences et donc il faut qu'on reste
attractif et que tu as fidéliser les
gens voilà
je vous en prie oui merci monsieur le
Président je voulais répondre à la
question de Monsieur le Député le seul
sur la sur la durée de vie du parc long
terme et les 80 ans alors d'abord le
processus d'évaluation de la durée de
vie des réacteurs et reste le même avec
des réévaluations tous les 10 ans et les
décisions qui sont prises tous les 10
ans pour une poursuite de l'augmentation
de la durée du vie du parc par période
de 10 ans donc aucun aucune évolution à
ce à ce propos qu'est-ce qui nous fait
regarder de façon plus proche ce sujet
serait-il possible d'amener des
réacteurs à 80 ans c'est tout simplement
le retour d'expérience de
l'international comme vous savez sans
doute nos collègues américains ont un
parc nucléaire qui est grosso modo une
dizaine d'années plus âgées que le nôtre
et d'ores et déjà aux États-Unis
plusieurs réacteurs ont obtenu donc une
licence d'exploitation de ces réacteurs
certaines de ces réacteurs donc jusqu'à
jusqu'à 80 ans donc nous nous
interrogeons de notre côté pour est-ce
que ce genre de choses pourrait être
aussi applicable chez nous donc ça
nécessite en fait une instruction
technique détaillée sophistiquée et qui
prendra du temps de façon à examiner à
la fois de point de vue technique d'un
point de vue scientifique chacun des
composants sensibles de ces réacteurs et
de pouvoir faire un diagnostic technique
de notre part sur ce sur ces composants
et bien sûr avoir le point de vue et la
décision de l'Autorité de sûreté finale
sur est-ce que c'est vraiment possible
ou pas donc il nous faut anticiper ce
processus d'analyse au processus
d'instruction et c'est pour ça que nous
regardons aujourd'hui dès aujourd'hui
cette démarche de très près
bien il y a d'autres questions je vais
laisser la parole à Delphine bateau qui
nous fait l'honneur de visiter notre
office ce matin mais d'abord merci
monsieur le Président et le premier
vice-président de m'accueillir à l'OPEX
je crois qu'il y a pas de hasard à ce
que plusieurs ministres le Parlement la
Cour des comptes le comité à la
transparence et l'encli et refusait à
plusieurs reprises
de s'engager sur la voie de cette
réforme
s'y ajoute le fait que on ne réforme pas
à la hussarde la sûreté nucléaire par un
cavalier législatif
et que ça c'est totalement contraire à
l'intérêt à l'intérêt national et à
l'intérêt de la sûreté j'ai trois
questions
la première je cherche à comprendre
exactement le schéma de cette réforme et
en fait lorsque l'on vous écoute les uns
et les autres on a l'impression qu'il y
a un concept une idée que rien
n'était établi
et rien n'est bordé sur comment ça
fonctionnerait exactement ma deuxième
question c'est qu'est-ce que vous vous
inspire
en particulier du point de vue de
l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire
lorsque les opérateurs contrôlaient
mettent en avant le fait que cette
réforme pourrait contribuer à une
simplification des procédures je cite
des propos qui qui ont été tenus il y a
quelques instants
et ma troisième question c'est est-ce
qu'il n'y a pas un risque pour la sûreté
mais elle-même et pour sa la confiance
qui qui est portée en elle de briser en
fait le consensus politique qui
s'est produit chaque fois qu'il a été
question pour l'Assemblée nationale et
le Sénat d'adopter des lois relatives à
la sûreté nucléaire autrement dit est-ce
que glisser
cette réforme par amendement dans une
loi dont le titre est accélération
de la relance du nucléaire n'est pas le
pire cadeau empoisonné pour la confiance
dans la sûreté nucléaire en France
j'ai également Philippe bolo qui
souhaite prendre la parole merci
monsieur le Président je vous remercie
toutes et tous pour votre présence qui
et vos propos qui qui nous permettent de
nous éclairer sur ce sujet qui va nous
occuper dans les semaines à venir les
objectifs et les missions de l'IRSN et
de la SN sont parfaitement vous avez
défini évidemment mais ils sont
parfaitement précisé dans la loi de 2006
relative à la transparence et à la
sûreté nucléaire pour la SN et dans le
décret du 10 mars 2016 pour l'URSS pour
faire simple mais vous l'avez dit IRSN
c'est la mission d'expertise et de
recherche et la SN qui consulter sur les
projets de décision
administratives de nature réglementaire
évidemment je fais cours ça va bien
au-delà mais ça permet au moins de bien
fixer les idées et ce schéma là permet
de porter un certain nombre de valeurs
que vous avez cité qui me paraissent
particulièrement importante de rappeler
celle de l'indépendance et de la
neutralité de l'expertise et de la
Recherche vis-à-vis de la décision celle
de la confiance vis-à-vis dans la
technologie nucléaire c'est une valeur
créée et celle de la garantie en termes
d'excellence de la sûreté nucléaire
française
le modèle avec la réorganisation qui se
profile et interroger notamment du point
de vue de ses compétences si vous l'avez
dit Monsieur Niel les compétences qui
ont été construites sur le long terme
des compétences transversales qui
touchent le domaine au-delà du nucléaire
de la de l'environnement de la santé du
domaine médical et cette transversalité
est absolument importante pour une
approche globale des sujets du nucléaire
et du des rayonnement ionisants avec ce
qui nous dessine face à nous nous avons
le risque de perdre de ses compétences
le risque de délitement des activités
internationales de l'URSS avec des
conséquences qui sont la disparition des
compétences et on voit combien la
disparition des compétences et peut être
dramatique sur les sujets d'une
nucléaire c'est ce qu'on a vu avec le Pr
c'est ce qu'on a vu aussi avec le les
soudures sur liées à la corrosion sous
contrainte et tout ça allant à l'inverse
des valeurs créées avec une perte de
confiance donc moi je m'interroge sur
les les prétextes et les motivations qui
qui motivent cette réorganisation un
premier signal faible était apparu lors
de précédents PLF au motifs d'économie
je ne pense pas comme vous sans doute
que les économies sur les sujets de la
sûreté nucléaire et la radioprotection
soit très pertinente et aujourd'hui on
nous avons aussi un autre prétexte une
autre motivation qui serait celle de la
fluidité de l'accélération des
procédures et les propos de Delphine
bateau étaient très précis sur ce sujet
là et moi je voudrais avoir une question
très simple si ça s'agit vraiment d'un
problème de fluidité et de
d'accélération des procédures selon vous
quel serait les choses à entreprendre
pour accélérer pour fluidifier les
procédures quelles seraient les verrous
à lever
donc je vois que les parlementaires sont
en raccord notamment avec les questions
aux internautes puisque voilà on a des
on a vraiment ces questions qui sont
similaires je laisse maintenant la
parole à Christine arrier
merci monsieur le Président bonjour à
toutes et tous alors vous comprendrez
qu'en tant qu' écologiste j'aurais
préféré ne pas participer à cette
réunion puisque nous sommes pas
favorables ni au nucléaire civil ni au
nucléaire militaire et à la fois par la
question pour la question du risque qui
est l'objet de notre réunion aujourd'hui
mais également par rapport à la question
des déchets donc on ne parle on parle si
peu quand on parle de nucléaire donc je
suis venue ici avec les mêmes questions
que Gérard le seul du pourquoi et je me
suis dit que faire finalement je
trouverais des réponses dans cette noble
assemblée et en réalité je n'ai trouvé
de réponse à aucune de mes questions et
du pourquoi cette réforme alors je ne
trouvais aucune réponse et une partie de
la salle j'ai entendu qu'effectivement
des termes tels que il nous revient ne
nous revient pas des maîtres Navy sur
cette nouvelle organisation envisagée et
nous nous mettrons en ordre de marche
votre indiquant que en effet sur ce
dispositif il pouvait y avoir des
interrogations le nouveau dispositif
pouvait y avoir des interrogations mais
sans nous dire en réalité qu'elles
interrogations et d'autres nous
expliquant que en effet il n'y avait pas
de littérature sur cette question
pouvant émettre des critiques sur le
modèle actuel nous permettant de
construire éventuellement sur la base de
ces critiques si elles avaient été à la
fois
élaboré et officialisé nous permettre
d'émettre un nouveau modèle une nouvelle
proposition sur la base de la critique
du modèle sur la base d'un benchmark qui
aurait pu être fait sur des
organisations qui
existent précédemment dans d'autres dans
d'autres pays alors moi je suis frappé
de l'absence de ces réponses je suis
frappé de la précipitation avec laquelle
les parlementaires sont réduits dans le
cadre de ce projet de loi se positionner
en l'absence de ses réponses sur sur ce
nouveau modèle et je suis également de
la plaidoirie PRODOMO de la SN parlant
comme si la décision était quasiment
prise en parlant au futur mais malgré
tout comme si la décision était prise
qui est assez malaisante je vais vous
dire pour la représentation nationale
que nous sommes parce que au bout du
compte on a l'impression que c'est
presque déjà fait donc presque déjà fait
sans avoir de réponse ça me paraît être
un vrai problème et le seul argument que
vous avez évoqué monsieur c'est de dire
finalement l'organisation et c'est le
seul que j'ai entendu qui puisse être
analysé c'est
en réalité l'organisation telle qu'elle
existe aujourd'hui n'est pas pertinente
et n'est pas efficace en cas de
situation de crise
ce qui veut dire que sans situation de
crise manifestement ça a l'air de
convenir mais on peut envisager une
situation de crise de ce qui ne fait que
confirmer ce que nous nous pensons c'est
que le nucléaire c'est un énergie qui
doit être géré avec l'idée d'une crise
et donc quelle est la crise que vous
envisagez qui nécessiterait une réforme
rapprochant vos deux structures et à ce
titre là des crises nous nous avons
beaucoup d'idées ce que peut y avoir de
crise le déficit d'eau en particulier ça
c'est une crise le les difficultés que
l'on peut avoir dans la construction
d'un EPR c'est une crise et également
ultérieurement le démantèlement d'une
hantée centrale nucléaire qui est aussi
une crise puisqu'on sait pas quoi faire
des déchets donc aucune réponse et
franchement j'aimerais bien être éclairé
et nous aimerions être mieux éclairé que
nous ne le sommes aujourd'hui
Angers de Préville merci monsieur le
Président et merci à tous les
intervenants de nous consacrer du temps
pour nous permettre d'être un peu mieux
éclairé sur ce qui est cette nouvelle
qui nous est parvenue et d'abord je
voudrais dire puisque le projet de loi
accélération d'énergie sur l'énergie
nucléaire nous l'avons eu au Sénat et
donc nous n'avons pas eu
cet amendement donc ce cavalier et qui
est une donc par rapport au Parlement je
trouve très cavalier quelque part de ne
pas nous avoir soumis à nous les
sénateurs cette cet amendement sur cette
éventuelle fusion et je voudrais
rappeler parce que ça est déjà été fait
cette historique de la confiance qui
s'est construit sur le nucléaire et qui
percute très concrètement là aujourd'hui
cette ce développement
pas prévu de 6 + 8 + éventuellement
encore plus de réacteurs nucléaires je
voudrais rappeler que le nucléaire est
très particulier que c'est un sujet qui
ne se compare à aucun autre que nous
avons en France un système de sûreté
nucléaire à nul autre pareil je pense et
que nous pouvons
nous nous pouvons être heureux du fait
que nous n'avons pas eu d'accident
nucléaire ce qui est arrivé dans
d'autres pays donc alors que nous sommes
le pays le plus nucléarisé au monde je
vais le dire comme cela donc voilà on a
une vigilance toute particulière et
notamment moi je l'ai dit en
intervention au Sénat déjà plusieurs
fois merci à EDF et à notre système de
sûreté nucléaire de ne pas avoir connu
ce qu'on connu d'autres pays voilà je
voudrais juste rappeler ça parce que
c'est la spécificité de cette de ces
cette production particulière
d'électricité pour pour moi je le
rappelle comme d'autres collègues le
système de sûreté nucléaire approuvé son
efficacité par le fait que nous n'ayons
pas eu d'accident majeur et ça n'est pas
une petite chose déjà je voudrais
rappeler que effectivement nous avons
une forme de transparence avec notamment
le lien essentiel qui a été établi avec
les citoyens ce que je salue de la part
du l'URSS et je me demande comme
d'autres parlementaires qu'est-ce qu'il
y a failli pourquoi est-ce qu'on remet
en cause ce système de sûreté nucléaire
est-ce que c'est trop coûteux est-ce que
l'actualité du prolongement des
centrales fait que il faudrait aller
plus vite et peut-être être moins enfin
je sais pas ce sont des questions que je
pose être moins regardant
voilà j'ai comme les autres
parlementaires le questionnement à ce
sujet là je ne comprends pas
et dites moi peut-être dans la nouvelle
organisation alors j'ai compris vous
avez mentionné monsieur de rosuk
l'approche mieux intégrée donc est-ce
que vous pouvez nous en dire plus voilà
peut-être pour mieux nous éclairer merci
oui merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
et merci à toutes et tous de prendre le
temps ce matin de venir répondre aux
questions de lopex je me je parlerai ici
bien sûr en tant que membre de cette
office mais aussi en tant que rapporteur
du projet de loi pour l'accélération qui
va arriver à l'Assemblée nationale dans
les semaines à venir
commencer par dire que pour ma part et
c'est pas un secret je suis extrêmement
attachée à cet industrie et je fais
contrairement à ma collègue plutôt
partie de ceux qui sont pro nucléaires
en revanche comme tous les
parlementaires ici présents je suis
extrêmement attaché à la sûreté du fait
de mon parcours et je considère qu'on ne
badine pas avec la Sûreté Nucléaire on
ne peut faire aucun compromis dans cette
sur ce sujet là et par rapport à ce que
j'ai pu entendre
certes les choses peuvent apparaître
peut-être comme acté quand on lit la
presse ici ou là mais le Parlement est
bien souverain l'Assemblée nationale
l'est aussi et c'est au député au
sénateur et à eux seuls qu'il reviendra
d'accès ou pas dans le projet de loi une
telle modification
c'est un projet de loi et ça a largement
été dit qui vise à simplifier à
accélérer les procédures et donc en tant
que rapporteur ma question est
extrêmement simple en quoi d'une manière
ou d'une autre le changement
d'organisation pourrait dans les années
à venir permettent de rationaliser
d'accélérer et de simplifier les
procédures en lien avec la construction
d'un éventuel futur programme EPR 2 je
vous remercie
enfin je laisse la parole à Gérard
Longuet
oui merci cher Président je souhaite en
effet à cet instant intervenir et poser
une question à Monsieur Bernard de VUC
et à tous ceux qui veulent rien y
répondre
je voudrais d'abord en effet remercier
les uns et les autres extérieurs au
Parlement du temps qu'il nous consacre
mais c'est votre métier c'est votre
passion c'est votre histoire et je
comprends que vous ayez envie depuis le
président de la nuclée jusqu'au
responsables de la recherche d'EDF je
crois et naturellement au patron de
l'IRSN la SN je ne parlerai pas de
François Jacques que je connais depuis
toujours depuis qu'il a présidé
l'endroit donc vraiment c'est ça on a
affaire à des gens sérieux et d'ailleurs
je constate
ce qui est plutôt sympathique c'est que
les parlementaires le sont tout autant
et et qu'il y a des prises de position
et des convictions différentes mais je
dois retrouver une image du Parlement
tel que je l'aime et tel que je le
fréquente depuis 45 ans ce qui est quand
même un petit peu long si vous me
permettez mais heureusement j'arrête
je me tourne vers bernardozet parce que
on partage tous cette nécessité absolue
de sécurité et je souscris totalement à
l'attitude de mon excellente collège
Jean sur le respect du Parlement et le
respect des procédures il n'est jamais
inutile sur des sujets aussi importants
de prendre un petit peu de temps je
ministre je connais ils veulent toujours
aller vite mais c'est pas si jamais
inutile de de perdre un peu de temps
pour parler et la question je voulais
vous poser la suivante en avril 1975 je
n'ai pas encore député mais j'étais déjà
commissaire du Gouvernement et j'ai
assisté à un débat intéressant où le
ministre de l'Industrie en charge de la
mise en oeuvre du programme Messmer mais
c'était Giscard président
et répondait au Parlement disant ben
voilà la loi c'est le
la grande stratégie de sur
l'indépendance énergétique de la France
dont le nucléaire est un atout essentiel
la mise en oeuvre c'est le gouvernement
ce que le Parlement a conquis et c'est
une excellente mesure pour l'opinion
française et pour l'acceptation par
l'opinion française
du programme électronucléaire
c'est que les questions de sécurité
sortent de la confidentialité sorte de
l'entre-soi et deviennent à travers les
lois de Médicis en particulier
des enjeux nationaux donc le la
stratégie nous aurons en débattre à
travers la PPE
on l'a accéléré un petit peu en
taquinant le gouvernement à l'occasion
de l'examen par le Sénat du texte sur
l'accélération puisque nous avons bâti
notre propre PPE mais enfin je sais bien
que l'Assemblée le regardera à sa façon
et c'est bien normal
ce qui me gêne dans le Cher Claude dans
ton objectif dual c'est qu'en réalité
on est beaucoup plus que deux et qu'on
le veuille ou non on est beaucoup plus
nombreux et il faut assurer une
coordination
l'idée d'un collège avec la compétence
et de la sagesse d'une expertise c'est
formidable mais c'est pas comme ça que
ça marche parce que il y a un acteur
auquel je voudrais rendre hommage c'est
EDF non pas à cause de DF mais parce que
vous exploitez depuis 50 ans des
58 réacteurs 56 aujourd'hui c'est des
millions d'heures de fonctionnement et
on ne peut pas imaginer que cette
compétence soit extérieure au débat vous
l'avez évoqué d'ailleurs on peut pas
imaginer que celui qui fait et qui fait
bien soit obligé de se taire en disant
non non dès qu'il y a une difficulté dès
qu'il y a une autorisation je laisse la
parole à des sages le collège à des
experts mais qui ne sont pas les mains
dans le cambouis qui gèrent pas le
fonctionnement des alternateurs en
permanence donc il y a déjà l'opérateur
aujourd'hui il y en a
mais en réalité il y en aura plusieurs
dans l'avenir parce que en effet
l'ouverture scientifique nous conduit à
penser qui est il y a d'ailleurs déjà le
projet New World il y aura des projets
de réacteurs différents nous aurons
d'autres acteurs
nationaux européens ou internationaux
ces gens-là ont de l'expérience on
imagine pas que vous ne bénéficiez pas
que le collège des sages ne bénéficient
pas de cette compétence
acquise par l'expérience pour continuer
ou par des innovations et des recherches
extérieures mais pourquoi la France se
priverait-elle de recherche qui sont
faites à l'extérieur dans des pays aussi
différents que que la Russie ou que les
États-Unis bon donc on a un besoin de de
d'informations internationales qui
interdit cette idée d'un système un
petit peu replié sur lui-même il faut
faire converger des informations qui
sont opérations qui doivent être
opérationnelles et qui doivent commander
la décision pour que la France ne soit
pas isolée vous avez dit c'est Monsieur
delalombe mais je partage complètement
son point de vue c'est que les l'opinion
les citoyens attentifs sont devenus
compétents pour beaucoup d'entre eux pas
tous certains sont passionnés d'autres
sont même partisans il y en a d'autres
qui sont part sont passionnés et qui ont
apporté une compétence et je vois dans
le débat de CGO puisque c'est une
affaire que je suis depuis 30 ans il y a
des questions qui n'ont été à l'ordre du
jour que parce que des gens passionnés
et compétents ont interrogé des experts
et ont posé aux experts des questions
auxquelles les experts n'avaient pas
vraiment songé à ce moment-là donc nous
avons un système qui est complètement
ouvert et c'est parce que le système est
complètement ouvert je le pense
profondément qu'il doit y avoir un lieu
de fédération de toutes ces informations
parce que sinon on va voir un système où
on va on est deux aujourd'hui c'est la
loi de 2006 alors là avec le collège la
SN qui a quand même son expertise on a
l'expertise qui n'a pas son collège donc
celui qui a le collège parle et celui
qui n'a pas de collège ne parle pas mais
en réalité c'est pas vrai tout le monde
parle et en dehors de ces deux qui
parlent et qui ont défini par la loi
vous avez les exploitants qui commencent
à dire attendez compte tenu des enjeux
il faudrait quand même pas négliger le
fait que nous avons des milliers
d'heures sur un réacteurs que nous avons
connu ces difficultés qu'on les a
réglées de telle façon et à ce moment-là
le constructeur ou votre
sous-traitant de premier rang ou
deuxièmement on va dire mais oui mais
nous dans l'autre pays on l'a fait et
donc vous devriez en tenir compte ce qui
s'est fait en Angleterre par exemple bon
ça veut dire que l'Autorité de sûreté
nucléaire doit être fédératrice et elle
doit être fédératrice de toutes les
informations utiles à la sécurité
nucléaire bon moi on m'a pas demandé mon
avis pour ce texte de loi vous savez que
je n'appartiens pas vraiment la majorité
gouvernementale mais je me dis que c'est
quand même pas complètement
idiot de réfléchir
non pas ce que nous avons fait qui est
bien fait et qui est satisfaisant mais à
ce qui va se passer dans un monde où le
nucléaire va être beaucoup plus dispersé
répartie où il des interactions entre
les uns et les autres et si nous n'avons
pas quelque chose d'un peu fédérateur
vous aurez
l'expert de l'expert de l'expert qui
dira mais n'entendez le collège doit
attendre son expertise qui elle-même
attend une autre expertise et tout cela
sera conflictuel avec l'arbitrage des
réseaux sociaux et bien comme je ne
souhaite pas cela je me dis que c'est
pas complètement idiot de se poser à la
question de la Fédération des
informations et de la décision non pas
du tout pour sanctionner les uns ou
sanctionner les autres ou glorifier les
uns et les autres mais parce que on a un
monde d'information qui est complètement
différent et comme nous avons la volonté
de décarboner et que le nucléaire reste
quand même la façon celui d'un homme
collègue à Rigi partage pas les mêmes
convictions mais nous a quitté
elle revient très bien bon on est on
n'est pas obligé de partager le même
conviction je respecte madame Delphine
bateau qui qui a des convictions
constantes et continues j'ai des
conseils
qui sont pas d'ailleurs continues parce
que de temps en temps j'ai voulu mais je
me dis que là il y a un monde ouvert il
faut un outil ouvert sur ce monde voilà
et c'est la raison pour laquelle vous
avez un beau une belle mission alors
est-ce que le gouvernement vous donne
des ordres non il vous donne une mission
vous pouvez dire ce que vous voulez nous
ça nous intéresse lorsque vous serez un
petit peu plus avancé de savoir où vous
en arrivez dans cette situation on a
quand même besoin de s'écouter les uns
et les autres le monde est unique et les
le danger climatique est unique et la
décarbonation je pense profondément
repose sur l'électricité non carbonée
dont le renouvelable et dont le
nucléaire
normalement
non on va pas entretenir un dialogue
particulier avec Gérard mais je ne pense
pas que ce soit ce que j'ai dit
parce que j'ai dit que la sûreté
nucléaire se nourrissait de la
confrontation des idées entre l'autorité
sûreté l'appui technique qui l'irsen et
les exploitants
et ceux qui me paraît le plus dangereux
c'est la séparation de la recherche
parce que s'il y a pas de recherche
c'est pas possible que la Sûreté
Nucléaire puisse progresser moi je me
souviens d'une conversation avec André
Claude Lacoste qui me disait la
recherche c'est ce qui nous a permis de
progresser il y a des choses que
l'Autorité de sûreté qui s'appelait pas
encore l'autorité sur t il s'appelait La
Décines a accepté il y a 10 ans qu'elle
n'accepterait plus aujourd'hui parce
qu'il y a eu l'apport de la recherche et
quand on va couper la recherche de
l'expertise là je crie d'Angers
moi j'ai pas la réponse c'est pour ça
que je suis content qu'il y a une
mission
un bien le il y a également pour pour
compléter avant de laisser à nouveau la
parole aux intervenants et également
donc de très nombreuses questions qui
nous ont été posées sur sur les réseaux
sociaux beaucoup ont été reprises par
par mes collègues parlementaires
peut-être une notamment qui qui sort du
lot qui n'a pas été évoqué qui concerne
notamment les exploitants sur
justement cette question de fluidité et
si les échanges
permettraient après réforme et bien de
d'être plus libre notamment dans dans
l'expertise intégrée au sein de
l'autorité voilà c'est une question
également complémentaire
je laisse peut-être la parole à nouveau
président de l'AS N
merci monsieur le Président merci
beaucoup mesdames et messieurs de vos
parlementaires de vos questions alors je
voudrais tout d'abord lever une
ambiguïté je ne pense pas
mettre placé délibérément dans la
situation où la réforme qui est proposée
serait adoptée c'est tout à fait clair
que le Parlement est souverain et que il
devra décider à la fois du type de
réforme du calendrier si si celle-ci est
adoptée et je n'ai pas d'avis personnel
sur le sujet j'ai simplement essayé de
répondre aux questions qui m'étaient
posées sur pourquoi qu'est-ce qui
changerait donc forcément d'une certaine
manière en essayant de répondre c'est un
peu une projection dans un schéma futur
enfin difficile de répondre aux
questions sans le faire et je voudrais
m'excuser si mes propos ont été mal
interprétés ce n'est pas cas c'est bien
évidemment la souveraineté totale du
Parlement
ensuite je voudrais reprendre un certain
nombre de propos tout d'abord dire que
je partage tout à fait les propos de
Charles Longuet qui peut-être partie
sur un très bien sur le fait alors je
reviendrai à la fin alors peut-être je
reprends la question dans l'ordre tout
d'abord
où en est-on dans les laboration de
première idée de schéma on a parlé d'une
lettre de mission de la calendrier
serrée moi je pense qu'il faut il faut
bien avoir en tête que l'idée de la
ministre si j'ai bien compris c'est
d'avoir un premier travail d'analyse
entre l'URSS le CEA et l'ASN sur 6-7
orientation a été confirmée quels sont
les premières étapes qui seraient
affranchir et quelle proposition
seriez-vous amenée à nous faire et la
première étape c'est si le gouvernement
décidé mais c'est sa décision de
proposer au Parlement par voie
d'amendement une évolution et ben c'est
quel serait finalement ces modifications
législatives et nous sommes
effectivement en mesure on y travaille
en tous ensemble de faire des
propositions d'amendements ensuite c'est
au gouvernement de décider si les
reprend les reprend pas dans quel donc
avec quel vecteur législatif c'est son
sujet mais ce que nous a été demandé par
la ministre dans la mission c'est de
dire finalement réfléchissez à ça donc
c'est une première première étape
ensuite il nous a pas été demandé de
faire des propositions qui
correspondrait à l'achèvement du
processus de réflexion de dialogue de
concertation qui doit s'instaurer si
cette orientation est confirmée il nous
a été demandé c'est dans le courrier de
proposer une méthode de travail une
méthode de travail pour pouvoir arriver
à des propositions et la méthode de
travail elle est forcément celle de
l'écoute celle de la prise en compte des
avis qui sont exprimés ici ou là là où
il y a un certain nombre d'avis qui sont
aimés par les parlementaires il y aura
certainement d'autres moments ou
d'autres parlementaires pourront émettre
des opinions certainement des auditions
il y aura aussi ce matin nous étions au
conseil d'administration de l'IRSN les
administrateurs ont émis également aux
poser des questions et mis des rés
indiquer un certain nombre
d'orientations donc tous ces éléments-là
doivent être pris en compte pour pouvoir
proposer une méthode de travail
permettant de déboucher le moment venu
vers des propositions concrètes il n'y a
pas de schéma est prêt établi les
frontières ne sont pas figés j'entends
beaucoup même si ce n'est pas ma
responsabilité première la question de
la recherche notamment de la recherche
imbriquée avec expertise et la recherche
qui est nécessaire pour pouvoir exercer
la mission de l'Autorité de sûreté c'est
un sujet qui est encore ouvert qui est
ouvert il n'y a pas eu de décision prise
c'est un sujet qui nous demandait
d'expertiser en regardant les synergies
qui doit y avoir entre les uns et les
autres donc la lettre de mission c'est
les premières propositions notamment
législatives si le gouvernement décidait
d'aller dans ce sens et deuxièmement une
méthode de travail permettant de prendre
connaissance de l'ensemble des des avis
des problématiques et de d'avancer sur
un projet d'organisation qui viendrait
de toute façon forcément dans un
deuxième temps et une fois que le
Parlement aurait voté la loi si j'ai pas
de le faire
on ne fera pas le travail si la réforme
n'est pas engagé bien évidemment et
c'est l'acte fondateur c'est la loi je
voudrais revenir sur la question de
l'accélération des simplifications des
procédures enfin etc qui a été exprimé à
plusieurs reprises d'abord c'est un
travail que nous menons en permanence
c'est pas parce que il y aurait une
réforme si le Parlement le décidait que
l'on changerait et que pour la première
fois on se poserait la question de la
simplification ou la réduction de la
complexification c'est d'ailleurs une
ligne que l'on partage tous à la fois
IRSN les exploitants sur le fait que il
y a vraisemblablement eu des des
décisions qui ont été prises par par le
passé je pense notamment aux obligations
faites dans le cadre des règles amateurs
qui ont amélioré la sûreté à l'évidence
puisqu'il y a eu des dispositifs de
sûreté supplémentaires qui ont été mises
en place mais qui ont peut-être
complexifié la conduite
des installations et donc on se pose
nous déjà aujourd'hui la question et on
est tous en face là dessus sur le fait
de dire attention dans les étapes
futures de réexamen voire même dans ce
qui a été fait soyons plus prudents ou
regardons de manière plus approfondie
les facteurs organisationnels et humains
qui peuvent être générés ou qui peuvent
être des sources de risque lorsque au
motifs réels d'améliorer la sûreté en
complexifie peut-être la conduite et et
voilà voilà un vrai sujet de
simplification sur lequel on se pose
est-ce que c'est pas lié à l'évolution
de l'organisation qui qui pourrait être
décidé c'est un véritable sujet
permanent et je crois qu'on doit le
faire parce que une installation
grelectrode complexe c'est une
installation qui présente des risques
donc le souci permanent de simplifier
d'éviter la complexification nous devons
l'avoir lorsque nous prenons les
décisions
accélérer les procédures le but n'est
pas d'accélérer les procédures c'est de
faire en sorte que c'est pas la finalité
que si la décision était prise dans le
cadre d'une rapprochement à la fois
expertise et instruction les interfaces
qui existent aujourd'hui qui ont été
très bien rappelés d'ailleurs par le
président
Longuet ce ministre c'est que bah il y a
finalement tout ça ça suppose des
échanges des interfaces avec les uns et
avec les autres dans une structure plus
ramassée il y a les échanges ne sont pas
les mêmes on peut fluidifier en matière
des choses donc le but c'est pas
d'accélérer c'est de d'avoir un système
qui soit plus efficient et je pense que
face aux multiples projets de prise de
position que nous aurons dans les années
à venir contenu de des décisions qui
pourraient être prises ou qui ont déjà
été prises mais qui produiront les
effets dans les dans les années qui
viennent c'est important qu'on se pose
la question c'est aussi notre
un souci permanent d'avoir une structure
qui soit un dispositif if global qui
soit efficace et j'en viens à la
remarque de
du ministre Longuet c'est que
effectivement
je crois qu'il y a tout à fait raison
l'idée c'est d'avoir un lieu de
fédération qui permette d'optimiser mais
d'optimiser ce que nous faisons en
relation avec les autres partis
prenantes et moi je suis assez sensible
à l'idée qu'il ne faut pas de système
qui soit étanche ou fermé il faut qu'on
soit en dialogue permanent avec les
autres j'ai essayé tout à l'heure dans
mon intervention de dire attention ne
voyez pas l'instruction comme étant et
l'expertise comme étant un
une étape on va se clos non on est
toujours en étroite relation avec
l'ensemble de l'écosystème et vous avez
dit une phrase qui m'a en tout cas un
élément qui est important c'est la
confrontation des idées c'est exactement
ce qui se passe monsieur le ministre
quand nous prenons une décision nous le
faisons en collège et je peux vous dire
que nous ne faisons pas toujours du
premier coup on n'est pas nécessairement
d'accord tous ensemble les membres du
collège et on a on pose bien souvent
puisqu'on n'a pas été impliqué dans la
structure dans l'expertise de nombreuses
questions qui parfois n'ont pas été
soulevé ou prise en compte par les
services et qui disent on n'avait pas vu
ça donc on leur envoie leur copie on
leur dit ça ce sujet là ça nous nous
convient pas approfondissez reprenez
contact avec l'IRSN avec les exploitants
approfondissaient et on est vraiment
dans une confrontation des idées et on
fait les choses de manière
itérative en rechercheant le consensus
donc c'est la confrontation des idées
elle est là et nous je me souviens très
bien de décision qui ont été prises ou
dans le processus d'instruction on a dit
ben maintenant on va écouter les
exploitants ça a pas été en chambre
uniquement entre nous les services il y
a 7 on a fait venir les exploitants et
on fait de nombreuses réunions avec
l'IRSN et avec les exploitants sur toute
une série de sujet on a parlé à la de la
poursuite d'exploitation des réacteurs
prolongement de fonctionnement de la 50
ans voire au-delà de 60 ans on a un
travail régulier tous ensemble avec les
exploitants sur ce sujet de la même
manière qu'on travaille avec les
exploitants nucléaires sur
tous les sujets qui aujourd'hui nous
préoccupent en matière de
cycle du combustible avec les risques de
saturation etc on travaille tous
ensemble donc pardon
je dis que être ouvert aux autres
confronter les Idées c'est quelque chose
qui existe et qui fonctionne et je me
rassure
la France investit sur SMS tout le monde
parle de SMS new Award est un projet
intéressant
si il n'est pas sécurisé au plan
national mais surtout sécurisé au plan
internationales il a aucun avenir
commercial
donc voilà vous avez besoin nous avons
besoin d'avoir une autorité de sûreté
qui soit capable d'aider nos industriels
qu'ils soient des ensembler ou des
équipementsiers à passer l'étape
internationale sinon on leur rend pas
service on leur remplacé et on se prive
de possibilités
alors pardon mais à ma connaissance les
coopérations internationales de la SN
sont extrêmement nombreuses et ça
crédibilité à l'échelle internationale
est forte donc j'aimerais comprendre
pour si si je prolonge la ce que dit le
premier vice-président j'aimerais
comprendre le rapport en fait parce que
sauf erreur de ma part il n'y avait pas
de problématique de crédibilité
internationale de la SN ou l'urssn ou
d'incapacité dans le cadre du modèle
actuel
ni à certifier des réacteurs ni à
échanger avec un certain et même à
apporter de l'expertise dans le cas de
des revues par les pairs etc
notamment de tout le poste foufou Shima
donc si si je me peux me permettre si
vous pouvez aussi revenir sur ce que
vous avez dit sur la gestion de crise
pour qu'on comprenne exactement quel
qu'est-ce qui rendrait nécessaire en
fait une évolution du schéma actuel
alors je reviens effectivement sur le la
gestion de crise parce que c'est un
exemple que j'ai cité ça ne se réduit
pas à ça mais un des exemples de
synergie en tout cas ne fonctionnement
qui me semblerait plus fluide et
améliorer c'est la situation de crise et
j'ai décrit le système actuel le système
actuel où il est finalement séquencé il
y a une analyse de la situation par
l'ISL en situation en liaison avec
l'exploitant il y a un certain nombre
d'outils qui sont utilisés pour faire
des des prévisions sur des projections
en cas de fièvre d'aggravation et de
conséquences de la situation de crise ça
c'est la mission de l'IRSN et ensuite il
est il est aujourd'hui dans le
l'organisation qui est prévu le résultat
de cette analyse et fourni à l'autorité
sur tes nucléaire qui a la
responsabilité de par la loi de
conseiller le gouvernement sur les
mesures à prendre
donc on est dans un système qui est
séquencé avec des équipes qui sont bien
structurées bien qui ont l'exercice qui
ont l'habitude de fonctionner dans des
exercices de crise où on stimule la
situation et ce dont on ce que l'on
s'appelle dont on s'aperçoit c'est que
effectivement ça introduit des
interfaces qui ne sont pas optimum dans
le cadre d'une situation réelle donc ce
que je dis c'est s'il y avait et c'est
un seul exemple une organisation avec
une seule cellule de crise avec une même
entité qui est responsable de la
totalité de la mission ça permet d'être
plus efficace dans la mission d'appuyer
au gouvernement
je reviens sur l'international vous avez
raison
tant la scène que l'IRSN joue un ont une
reconnaissance internationale qui est
extrêmement forte extrêmement forte et
ça c'est un résultat d'actions de nos
prédécesseurs depuis de très nombreuses
années chacun est d'une certaine manière
reconnue dans son cercle de compétence
la SN vis-à-vis des autres autorités que
les graissait d'ailleurs rencontrent
également des relations avec les autres
autorités et nous avec les les autorités
des pays étrangers et parfois avec des
experts techniques des pays étrangers
donc en fait chacun d'entre nous a des
relations et chaque et de manière
disjointe avec des autorités étrangères
et des experts étrangers
nous sommes une équipe globale qui avons
l'avantage de bénéficier d'une
expérience assez hors norme dans le
monde nucléaire
elle est liée au parc nucléaire au fait
qu'il est standardisé et qu'il y a
beaucoup d'années de retours
d'expérience pour un parc sans leur
disait elle est liée au fait que nous
maîtrisons en France la totalité de la
chaîne du combustible à la fois amont et
avale elle est liée aussi en France au
fait qu'en France nous avons une
politique exemplaire en matière de
planification sur la problématique des
déchets il y a bien sûr des questions
qui se posent il y a des controverses
mais par rapport au pays étrangers nous
sommes en avance et nous on nous le dit
d'ailleurs quand nous avons eu récemment
la convention commune
à la UEA où on a présenté la politique
française en matière de gestion des
déchets et il y a eu une bonne pratique
de nos pères liées au fait que nous
avons un système participatif puisqu'il
y a eu un débat public sur le cinquième
PNG mdr ce qui ne se fait nulle part
ailleurs dans le monde parfois il y a
pas de plan et bien évidemment pas
d'associations du public donc nous
n'avons absolument pas à rougir de ce
que nous faisons et nos pratiques sont
largement reconnues internation voilà
donc je pense que par rapport
au sujet à venir je pense qu'il faut il
faut avoir en tête et je pense que
c'était vraiment un esprit de du
ministre Longuet c'est c'est que
le réchauffement climatique
l'orientation mondiale de la
réorientation des sources de production
électrique
d'origine fossile vers d'autres types de
production va conduire à un nombre en
tout cas c'est aujourd'hui ce qui se dit
un nombre important de pays une
quarantaine de pays qui ne sont pas
nucléarisées à s'ouvrir au nucléaire et
je pense que une un moyen de de faire en
sorte que le niveau de sûreté de ce
futur nucléaire dans ces pays qui n'ont
pas d'expérience et qui n'ont pas en
général d'infrastructures de contrôle
qui n'ont pas d'autorité soit au bon
niveau c'est que nous puissions nous
aussi c'est ce que nous avons on a des
contrats de coopération leur fournir une
assistance sur le contrôle en leur
disant ben voilà une organisation
d'expertise et de contrôle en sûreté ça
doit passer par ou tel état ça doit se
structurer de tel ou telle manière il
peut très bien y avoir des mesures
d'accompagnement dans le cas de la
responsabilité qui est la nôtre c'est
pas de la promotion du à l'export du
d'une guerre française c'est de dire
nous on est capable d'aider des pays et
des autorités qui découvrent pour la
première fois les activation nucléaires
pourraient bénéficier de notre
expérience alors si la réforme était
décidée je pense que c'est aussi un
point un point positif qui pourrait
voilà mais je suis désolé
pour peut-être les également
oui peut-être pour dire un mot sur les
questions qui ont été posées sur le mot
fluidité et instructions techniques
je crois que ça je crois que ça a été
dit il faut que vous réalisiez en fait
le volume d'activité que les équipes EDF
donc consacre à l'exploitation des
réacteurs et aux analyses de sûreté en
particulier donc nous avons plusieurs
milliers en fait
d'ingénieurs qui travaillent aujourd'hui
sur ces sur ces dossiers et
l'instruction donc avec l'Autorité de
sûreté elle se fait dans un dialogue
technique constant donc ce dialogue il
est constant à la fois en direct avec la
SN dans le cas des appareils sous
pression c'était évoqué par le président
de réduc tout à l'heure où là nous avons
vraiment des échanges avec de
l'expertise technique qui est embarquée
complètement dans les structures de
l'Autorité de sûreté dans sa forme dans
sa forme actuelle avec des échanges
extrêmement pointus et avec de
l'expertise de très très haut niveau qui
existe des deux côtés les experts de la
SN en matière de matériaux n'ont rien à
envier aux experts leur permettez-moi de
dire d'EDF mais aussi de toute
l'industrie française métallurgique
française voire internationale donc on a
là déjà un dialogue d'expert de premier
plan entre des gens de l'ASM et des gens
d'EDF nous avons aussi avec les
collègues de l'IRSN des dialogues
extrêmement pointus sur d'autres sur
d'autres sujets de l'instruction de
sûreté et là par contre le dialogue il
est à 3 et donc là la complexité c'est
évidemment plus compliqué de parler à
trois que lorsqu'on est à deux
simplement parce qu'il y a des
itérations parce que il y a des choses
nouvelles qui apparaissent et parce
qu'il y a des choses qui peuvent
intervenir dans un dans un processus
relativement long c'est une simplicité
fin c'est une me semble-t-il une
évidence et sachant que nous avons des
niveaux d'expertise des deux côtés ou
des trois côtés en la matière qui sont
très importants il y a un point de
rapprochement qui se fait sur lequel je
voudrais insister c'est vraiment le
groupe permanent expert donc le groupe
Herman des experts c'est en fait une
instance qui réunit à la fois des
représentants de l'ASM de l'IRSN de la
société civile et des personnes qui sont
des anciens industries y compris des
anciens des anciens exploitants c'est un
sens en fait permet d'avoir de vrais
débats et de mettre sur la au niveau des
experts donc dans le fond vraiment des
affaires mais aussi sophistiquées
qu'elle soit un vrai un vrai dialogue
technique donc nous sommes vraiment très
attachés à ce que quel que soit
l'organisation que vous déciderez que en
fait ce dialogue se poursuit qu'il
puisse être même encore mieux ordonnancé
dans la nomination des des experts qui
participent sous le la direction et sous
le pilotage de l'Autorité de sûreté sur
les dossiers également qui peuvent y
être présentés à la fois de l'irsan
aujourd'hui et d'EDF et avec une une
concomitance de de présentation on
souhaite vraiment que ce dialogue puisse
se poursuivre
sur qu'est-ce que ça veut dire la
fluidité est-ce que c'est une
simplification en fait la fluidité c'est
facilité ce dialogue mais c'est aussi
être capable d'utiliser les meilleures
techniques disponibles je crois qu'il
faut vraiment le répéter même si on a
une flotte de 56 réacteurs nous avons
fait progresser la sûreté de nos
réacteurs au cours du temps ce que nous
faisons aujourd'hui avec les quatrième
décennales de nos réacteurs 900 c'est de
les mettre finalement je dirais
quasiment si vous permettez Monsieur de
roduc quasiment ou de façon très proche
du niveau de sûreté des réacteurs
européens
c'est quand même un sacré défi un sacré
challenge et ça nous a amené nous
exploitants à prendre en compte des des
innovations technologiques que nous
avons intégré directement dans les dans
les réacteurs donc ça je pense qu'il
faut vraiment le souligner donc en fait
nous voulons aller au meilleur technique
disponibles exploitable
vis-à-vis de la recherche donc je suis
le directeur de la recherche de DF donc
j'en parle à l'aise le temps de la
recherche et le temps d'exploitation ne
sont pas les mêmes la recherche évolue
tout le temps et il faut pas la brider
lorsque nous nous faisons une
modification sur un de nos réacteurs
avant qu'elle touche l'entièreté d'un
palier il faut plus de 10 ans donc vous
imaginez bien que si on demande à la
recherche de s'adapter aussi vite ou
aussi lentement que ce que nous faisons
dans le déploiement de modifications on
n'y arrive pas donc il faut et c'est la
recommandation que permettait de faire
il faut l'ASN quelque soit
l'organisation retenue et la maîtrise
d'ouvrage de cette recherche donc à
l'année le pilotage qu'elle puisse
définir les enjeux qu'elle puisse
décider des moyens qu'elle puisse
décider des acteurs qu'elle sollicitent
au passage acteur interne
ou externe n'ayant pas la prétention non
plus nous Français de penser que
d'autres acteurs internationaux seraient
moins compétents que nous en termes de
recherche et auquel on ne pourrait pas
faire appel je signale que beaucoup
d'autorités de sûreté étrangères font
aussi appel à d'autres acteurs y compris
en dehors de leur territoire et y
compris
très différents donc je pense qu'il est
il est extrêmement important que ce
processus puisse se faire pour une
meilleure sûreté de nos de nos réacteurs
je voulais faire trois points après pas
je voulais rappeler que le système dual
fonctionne aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'il y a déjà été dit je crois
que Bernardo qu'on pourra confirmer ça
le diapajoma m'arrêter quelques secondes
sur le concept de ce qui s'appelle dans
le langage international la technique
les organisations techniques de sûreté
c'est les IRSN
en fait
les conventions internationales
indiquent qu'il y a dans chaque pays qui
a du nucléaire une autorité de sûreté et
les conventions internationales et
indiquent aussi que il y a un besoin de
d'expertise technique il y a une grande
variété de modèles en fait il y a pas de
modèle qui se ressemblent il y a une
grande variété de modèles sur la manière
dont cette expertise technique on appuie
de la de l'Autorité de sûreté parce que
la sûreté nucléaire c'est une ça
nécessite c'est sa science a base comme
on dit en anglais c'est basé sur la
science lighting on a besoin de
compétences donc la manière dont cette
expertise technique apporte son appui à
l'autorité il y a énormément il y a un
document de la yoi qui existe
qui qui répercut ça qui répercut
d'ailleurs les obligations des TSO dans
leur organisation donc ça c'est un point
très important il y a une grande grande
variété de modèle il y a le modèle NRC
représente comme intégré mais il faut
quand même noter qu'il y a une quinzaine
de pour cent de l'appui technique à la
NRC qui est fait dans les laboratoires
nation très pointu
il y a le système français il y a sn.sn
mais je pense qu'il faut il faut aller
au-delà de du rattachement
organisationnel c'est il faut
s'interroger sur tout le système par
exemple
les Japonais qui ont aussi un TSO dans
ce qui s'appelle JAEA le CEA japonais
avec un certain nombre de de Chinese
wall si je peux me permettre les
Japonais pour pour ces histoires de
d'indépendance par rapport à l'organisme
si je prends les Japonais ou les ou les
ou la NRC les réunions du Collège sont
publiques donc la controverse elle se
fait publiquement voilà donc je pense
qu'il faut tout prendre c'est à dire que
il faut s'interroger sur est-ce que
cette intégration c'est pas aussi lié
est-ce que c'est pas une manière
d'ailleurs de de garantir cette
séparation expertise
décision et puis mon dernier point c'est
on voit que ces sujets sont complexes en
fait ils résistent mal à simplification
et jouer rappeler qu'il y a SN
évidemment tout à fait disponible
pour échanger car présentation nationale
pour approfondir les suit comme la crise
ou la fabrique de la décision qui a un
objet complexe avec beaucoup
d'interactions techniques mais pas
seulement technique avec les opérateurs
au premier chef c'est le métier
quotidien des RSN d'interagir avec les
opérateurs aujourd'hui j'ai pas fait la
comptabilité avant de venir mais je suis
sûr qu'il y a plein de réunions entre
EDF et les experts de l'Institut et la
SN et puis il y a aussi d'autres acteurs
dans la société civile
la représentation nationale on est
clairement à disposition pour
approfondir les sujets qui ne
mériteraient
oui merci Monsieur président en fait
juste pour préciser ce que je vais dire
qu'il sera peut-être il paraîtra
peut-être un peu décalé par rapport au
débat moi je vais pas je préjugue pas de
la bonne forme d'organisation j'ai dit
que j'avais dire là-dessus je me permets
juste de réagir parce qu'il y a eu deux
trois éléments deux trois commentaires
qui ont été faits sur la recherche et là
par profession je me sens quand même un
peu obligé de préciser deux trois choses
la première c'est ce qui a été dit sur
les affaires de conflit d'intérêt je
pense qu'il faut qu'on ait tous
conscience de la situation telle qu'elle
existe aujourd'hui c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui pour faire de la
recherche il faut qu'est-ce qu'il faut
faire il faut acquérir des données il
faut faire des manipulations il faut
faire des expériences il faut avoir des
outils instrumentaux
typiquement l'irfn procède à ce genre de
choses via des instruments il y en a un
il s'appelle cabri c'est un réacteur qui
est sur le centre CEA Cadarache et qui
puisque justement on ne veut pas que une
entité impliquée dans la sûreté puisse
s'auto-évaluer n'est pas opéré
par l'ISL mais opéré par le CEA
autrement dit aujourd'hui soyons clairs
le CEA opère une installation
expérimentale qui rend des services
j'imagine à mon voisin de confirmer
Ali Hassan et pourquoi j'insiste
là-dessus c'est parce que c'est par
rapport à ce qui a été dit tout à
l'heure sur le fait que dès lors qu'il y
a une installation qui est au CEA on
peut pas y faire confiance et puis on
peut pas tout ça va pour faire des
choses atroces qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
concrètement sur cette installation
expérimentale là qui a connu des
problèmes qui a connu un problème
technique donc il y a eu des réparations
qui ont été proposées mais qui a fini
par expertiser la réparation et bien un
expert belge on est allé chercher un
expert à l'étranger donc c'est ni les
racines qui que ce soit qui a pu
expertiser donc s'il s'agissait
d'expertiser les installations de
recherche du CEA de manière à avoir une
indépendance bah il faudrait aller
chercher ailleurs et toute façon ça
serait ni lire SNI que ce soit sur les
cas où ce sont des installations qui
visent je préfère mettre ça sur le sur
la table parce que
j'avoue que j'ai été un peu un peu
chatouillé de d'entendre que ce prétexte
de l'installation était tu vois il se
passait potentiellement n'importe quoi
bon ça c'est un premier point le
deuxième point c'est sur la recherche
moi au bout du bout je vais vous dire je
suis pas sûr de savoir ce que c'est que
la recherche en sûreté je connais la
recherche je connais la science je
connais la physique je connais la chimie
je connais je connais des domaines parce
que quand on va devoir savoir si la cuve
elle tient bah ça va être le
comportement de l'acier ça va être bon
etc et donc je pense que l'acquisition
du savoir fondamental qui se fait dans
les règles de la science qui se fait
dans l'ouverture complète ben ça c'est
de la recherche et alors excusez-moi
mais elle est dans les universités elle
est au CEA elle est au CNRS et nous
travaillons c'est bien pour rien qu'il y
a des unités mixtes entre le CEA le CNRS
université nous travaillons ensemble
pour produire ça et donc je pense pas
qu'il faudrait penser que à la fin il y
a une recherche qui est dans l'isolement
qui permet la progression et puis et
puis il y a une autre recherche qui ne
servirait à rien je suis désolé la
recherche du pardon est tout respect je
dois mais à mes collègues à droite
de recherche n'existerait pas s'il n'y
avait pas les universités le seal CNRS
parce que quand on parle de Qatar on a
parlé tout à l'heure de Qatar du code
mais où est la compétence principale qui
a développé ses codes excusez moi elle
est aussi loin quand on parle d'un
certain nombre de phénomènes
physico-chimiques où elle est elle est
dans université elle est au Cinéas etc
donc je voudrais pas qu'on se méprenne
sur la question de la recherche il y a
une recherche qui est active qui est
vigoureuse et qui comme le disait
international parce que dans les on
clamerait que on est bon qu'on a qu'on a
des bons résultats tout seul en France
mais mais on fait rire tout le monde
donc c'est c'est bien parce qu'il y a
des il y a des communautés
internationales qui challenge ça et donc
je voudrais quand même remettre ça à sa
place parce que ça me donnait un peu la
pression que finalement la recherche qui
était aussi à ne servait à rien ou ne
contribble et et par rapport à ce que
disait que le bureau tout à l'heure
évidemment qu'on a fait les preuves sur
la recherche on n'a pas fait des
progression achat parce qu'on a fait de
la recherche en sûreté on a fait des
progrès parce qu'on a fait on a fait de
la recherche on a fait de la science
pardon pardon de le dire c'est un peu un
plaidoyer pour la science
bien écoutez merci
à l'ensemble des intervenants j'ai
conclure sur vos propos Monsieur Jacques
qui nous permettent à la fois de
replacer aussi l'enjeu de la science au
sein des questions de sûreté nucléaire
et qu'elles ne sont pas effectivement un
champ unique en elle-même et que
évidemment l'ensemble des champs
disciplinaires contribuent ou peuvent
contribuer à un niveau de qualité de
sûreté nucléaire le plus le plus fort
possible merci encore une fois à
l'ensemble des intervenants merci à
l'ensemble des parlementaires qui se
sont mobilisés ce matin et on le sait
avec le calendrier qui n'est pas simple
avec la réforme des retraites en ce
moment
qui ont quand même bien voulu participer
à ces débats je sais que nous aurons
l'occasion très prochainement
de poursuivre ces débats lors des les
différentes commissions et en hémicycle
à l'Assemblée nationale
et simplement vous dire que donc nous
rendrons nos conclusions donc sur ce
travail et donc d'ici une dizaine de
jours afin que nous puissions éclairer
le Parlement dans son ensemble sur ces
enjeux qui vont très rapidement revenir
vers nous
comme je le disais au sein des
commissions et au sein de notre
hémicycle merci à tous et je lève la
séance